welcome to my show
hey
hey yeah your skinny boy all right hey i
have a question and i have a question no
yes how about this
no right away let's move on it's
important to ask a question because i'm
looking at you i don't like this either
okay i haven't seen you in person right
so
we you don't get some we know that right
now it's not a big deal but
if you do a special you know mm-hmm
casper the narrow ghost hahaha that'd be
hilarious nah dude right but that
wouldn't be that funny but you got to
get some color dude i just i'm i'm a
different you know what it is dude what
i'm built different we have a backyard
though yeah yeah yeah yeah but i'm built
different yeah what does that mean dude
like just
you know rappers say that [ __ ] yeah i'm
different i'm you know how like like
[ __ ] workout guys would be like built
different yeah yeah they i am well not
them i am yeah you should wear a shirt
that says beast mode that'd be sick that
would be very cool you know your belt
might be very yeah you're built like if
i had hey hey man turn your chair down
yeah yeah just give me the shoulder yeah
yeah if there was like a four cameras it
was all it was all and we couldn't and
there was a tiny little sliver like
you're the guy who's
and kind of gets through it you know
what i mean like
i don't i don't think that's anybody
you gotta [ __ ] you got to seal the
doors even a little crack and he [ __ ]
[ __ ]
like an x-men
yeah the awkward guy you don't do
anything you just get in there and
you're like and you're all drawn so i
don't help at all he doesn't have to
keep the [ __ ] wall you don't help at
all yeah you drink all the water somehow
to get like and then we all die and save
life oh i don't you die anyway yeah like
that's a bad movie i know i know but
that's
that's what you would start hey dude
you're behind me right yeah it's
bothering me yeah yeah shoulder
cold shoulder yeah
behind your shoulder rolling rolling
right so let me take this off
uh obviously if you guys don't know who
these two are i don't know what the hell
you've been watching over there is chris
delia one of the funniest man on the
goddamn planet yep has a
the biggest podcast in the world
congratulations
and that's me saying congrats you said
it was called you're welcome right you
says you're not guys not called you're
welcome
yes so do i
just to calvin
yeah i sing to him on the phone that's
you i facetime him dude no you're
outside yeah outside across the street
son you know what
he's been sending emails yeah now i want
you guys to know that brenda and i have
a two thousand dollar bet
on the uh peter yan of course danny san
hang and fighting okay and if you don't
pay me you're gonna see me beat brian
with my bare hands after the show that'd
be fun that'd be good context all right
good yeah yeah i can't wait yep
who are those guys that you just
mentioned oh okay so they're the fight
that's going on that's right they're the
co-main event can you name one ufc
fighter yes go ahead the rock
good
good yeah what weight he fights at what
do you know what weight he fights the
rock is 550 pounds there you go that's
right this is all correct 550 pounds
those are actual
wwe that's good
all right let me get this reading kids
all right everybody uh this holiday
season we are giving thanks to our
friends at manscaped the global leaders
in below the belt grooming the manscape
performance package 4.0 or as i like to
call it the perfect package for your
package will beat any holiday spread
this year
gift yourself manscape because you're
all hairy down there man all right
once you get the package inside you'll
find a little lawnmower 4.0 trimmer it
you can do it in the in the dark you can
shave your pubes is that true yeah man
if you want to get weird do in the dark
doing the shower all right they get the
weed whacker definitely something you
could use b for your ears and nose hair
because that's not fun crop preserver
ball deodorant okay crop reviver toner
we got boxer briefs in there and a
little travel bag to put all your stuff
in all right we got you covered man
yup little ball bag the gift of manscape
is the gift that keeps on giving and you
want to be shaved down like a seal this
holiday season get 20 off and free
shipping by going to manscape.com
cfc that swipes off free shipping by
going to manscape.com cfc be thankful
this holiday season for the best gift of
all from manscape your balls will thank
you
good read thanks guys i like that end
when you did that did you yeah it was
cool man you think you're stronger than
the rock
uh
maybe at some things i doubt hey yeah
but he's constantly just working out
yeah like never stop that's all he does
yeah i don't know well how big he's as
big he's as tall as you right like what
are you six
six four he's probably six uh he's about
six four in an elevator the rock is all
natural though brennan is doing nothing
but steroids so there's a difference
right
yeah if i was on his protein powder that
would be pretty close i don't know dude
his genetic certainly he's obsolete big
strong guy so the better question would
be if not you you right
you're past that but for you chris if
you got on that stuff you think you
could get like uh like john cena i gotta
get on that [ __ ] i thought about getting
on that [ __ ] and just being [ __ ] for
real different just a different guy yeah
and just [ __ ] yoked as [ __ ] like
white girl not but nice you know what i
mean like i'm a nice guy yeah do you
know what i mean
hey how you doing but like but like when
you shake my hand you're like oh that's
a tree trunk okay yeah
i know okay well i think what would
happen because because my frame yeah is
from the from the chest i hate saying
it's got a frame but no but it's
ridiculous right
and and dude no but
my my legs are thin yeah yeah and that's
and that's it but not here though but
right here above my knee they go crying
they go crying
because you know the drop it looks like
a teardrop they don't cry and my hips
are like this
no no yeah dude and so it's crazy so
people call me chicken legs because it
looks like i have full chickens in my
legs no that's not good yeah yeah
yeah so i don't think that's what it is
because what happens is
you you are genetically not
an athlete right so you don't have you
don't have the ability there's no power
from the waist down no no
you got tits yeah no you don't have an
ass right hits bro what i have an ass do
you it's crazy not really hard to go
crazy
yep now if you if you
saw stuff in my car if you saw stuff
really
yeah i think i'm gonna one day though if
you went to zoo culture and started dead
lifting and and squatting yeah what
would happen you you're the expert would
i blow up if i did but chris got big
just doing the that whatever [ __ ]
videos he's posting his house like
jumping on like boxing oh i jump crazy
around i jump around crazy dude yeah you
want to go that jumps
[Music]
all right because it happened right yeah
don't be like actually yeah you know you
actually got like like you didn't
believe in me
you believe in me i know but this [ __ ] i
look like captain america when his
shield is at rest right it's on his back
i don't know that's me dude oh like a
turtle yeah yeah your turtle yeah yeah
what what have you ever been in the sun
though why don't you get out dude
you know what it's like you're the one
all scared of kovalev sun beats that
[ __ ] i'm not scared i'm here bro you
guys have coveted for sure dude we got
vaccinated and we had covered what's up
daddy we like the x-men of covington
bulletproof yeah bulletproof yeah sneeze
in my [ __ ] mouth chris
no that's even not see what happened
pre-code what happens
nothing yeah well it would be gross no i
will lick your face in your mouth uh
there will be a lot of weird memes about
it that would happen yeah sure so yeah
um no um nah i i didn't get covered yet
and uh i'm chilling dude are you bubble
boy people talking people
dude i'm out and people are [ __ ]
talking to me and they people lean close
i feel like the people i feel like the
anti-vaxxers lean closer now just to
prove a point sure yeah hey real quick
okay be honest with us all right do you
wear a mask in the car
no
i thought you were that that's a stupid
[ __ ] thing
because he calls me from his car and he
has a mask on he just calls me like this
and
he never has a clown mask because he
wants me to see the smirk on his face
he'll call me like he's won something he
just calls me up and i'll be like he
facetimes and he's just going like this
yeah
and i'm like i'm already annoyed that's
nice yeah but you're a good friend it's
all good baby yeah see that bothers me
it's all good and then he moves doesn't
matthew mcconaughey has that thing just
keep living dude me and matthew
mcconaughey are like right there
together oh he's running for god just
keep living i like him very much
a little bit when he's sitting there
like when he's making that inspirational
speech
no no listen to me man
anyone who makes inspirational speeches
yeah just stop doing that that's right
well then stop doing it tough mudder
because they give one hell of an
inspirational speech before you run that
tough mudder i don't think i'll ever run
tough mudder man why
you wouldn't run it with not
it'll be dirty have you ever i don't
think you run [ __ ] hey hey [ __ ] dude a
little mud yeah nah i just like
what do you wear nothing what do you
wear just your shirt and tee
ah he's grooming his son to be exactly
like him his son is one years old and he
spends all day with the sun which is
beautiful but his son there was he had a
nice coffee with a straw and you see his
son just go like this
son writes down and goes and he starts
to sip the coffee at one and chris goes
yeah
be like me
dude dude i let my kid drink coffee he
drinks my hot coffee man black coffee
the first time i went to give him coffee
i was like because he's like he didn't
want to grab he doesn't want to grab
anything you know he grabbed the straw
and kristen was like oh well i don't
know i mean give him a taste because you
know it's bitter i like it black i'm
real man and i don't put [ __ ] in it
except for ice cream
but if you were gonna put stuff you
you're gonna drink crappy you put the
stuff in it stevia you
sweet
don't
tart
[Music]
she was like it's true it's true
sweet tart tartan ass and they're like
this hey i love that i come out i'm
about to my brian dude i love when fans
go yeah brian show i yelled out be gay
out yeah he doesn't like that constantly
no you guys give me nicknames and then i
just never lose them
yeah i hope they don't say that
in breath this thursday oh no you [ __ ]
yourself up
i'm saying i hope no
you're there thursday friday well
thursday friday when i'm doing it now
why aren't you doing saturday because i
got the fight companion
november 6th oh yeah that's all [ __ ] man
but i but november 11th to the 14th when
i'm on off the hook
that's in naples when you're you want an
mc for me no dude in
naples come out it's nice to have 10 in
front of you you go 15. if you want i'll
throw you an extra five that's all you
got now you haven't done stamina yeah
but dude i've got 20. no i'm not no he's
been getting up rush
you shake
alright so what was i saying
dude that's nice oh calvin yeah so we
drank coffee and my my and kristen was
like you you have it you know give it to
him he won't like it and he goes
and he goes ma
dude he's yeah he's me
okay
no he's me i get it now now that i have
a son yeah
he's me dude i'm an aide another me
that's so egotistical no
i could die now my lineage
we'll move on chris that's not the
reason i have a kid you have to there's
no i love him i know but it's also part
christie he's
me
dude he's part christian but when you
look at him in the face yeah he's
nothing but me
dude he has the eyebrows
yeah he's me dude his eyebrows are on
like mine on top of his head like a
[ __ ] cartoon okay we are one night
chris you can't your kids come through
you not from you you've got to be a
little bit less
like egotistical about this
does he have a shoe collection already
like that yeah he does he doesn't have
he is my spawn no he doesn't have your
hair no but he will dude i was blonde
when i was a kid i was a little boy dude
all right and then one day i go like
this
nah and it goes
and it's dark because if you're a blonde
haired man yeah you're a [ __ ]
you are dude you are a lot of blonde
yeah
dudes at my shows and that's
no
cap that's zero cash tell brian what
that means so that means it's not a lie
i'm telling you the truth
and i don't want any blonde
men at my show and here's the other
thing too if you're a blonde man and
this is a rule you don't wear a leather
jacket because no matter what you're not
that cool
no leather nope
john john blagov and and and the other
san diego
yeah and cory's saying we had a lot of
blonde fighters in this in this thing
coming up
i think hooker has blind hooker does too
dan hooker doesn't sandy he's a handsome
dude by the way i'd like to just before
we get into this i got can i give you my
picks for this for this
sure all right so i got peter yan of
course and i'm gonna win two thousand
dollars yeah dude you better [ __ ] pay
me i'm going to pay you all right i'll
pay up i don't have to just make your
friend pay them no i don't have to i got
i got i'm i'm going glover you too yeah
i just i'm rooting for him
man you don't know how to do a fist bump
no i don't know how to do it do a fist
bump
ah [ __ ]
these pigs let me take a hand
dude just make a fist hold the fist
though you ain't not a pun
um chris real quick you watch no sports
no i saw football no fighter mcgregor
uh
bieber yep
[ __ ] got
connor
mcgregor that's a long time ago mack
hold and that was crazy but i will say
this is a good fight i got in the left's
like the next big thing my favorite guy
is
another another pakistani with a chin
beard yeah uh zendaya style lender
he literally said that he literally
style underneath that style ender is so
good
what's his name
izzy would you call him izzy
i like that guy i saw i was uploading
one night uh watching youtube videos
this is that guy he's mad
unbelievable yeah i love that when he
says you would like him to be a swag
yeah yeah i see them no i know i'm
joking around i know what his name is
when he's fighting he's a puma athlete
like he's a beast when he's fighting
calvin and there's that that clip where
he says there's no problem here i'm
prepared to die and he goes out that's
what i do uh in now in the middle of my
set when i'm on stage i'm prepared
people are just laughing their [ __ ]
ass off
and i and i very quietly say
there's no problem i'm prepared to die
only about half of them hear me because
the laughter is deafening okay
why do you say there's no problem here
the way you talk about your son talk
about your son normally
okay okay what's his middle name oh [ __ ]
um
dude you don't even know
matthew
is it yep because that's my brother's
name that's bill love it calvin matthew
delia i did the same thing yeah
matthew no my brother's name you didn't
name him after your brother you have a
brother yeah you've never met jay
kidding bro get with it man there is no
problem i am prepared to die
now i got it
yeah
so what's up guys so here we have a live
event this is what you wanted me to do
right yes here we have a live event
we've got three chicks sitting on the
sideline and we've got a guy here now
who are these guys can you explain it
now over here in the red shorts we've
got o's dimir and then uh on the black
shorts here backing up we've got enclave
oh nice gadir's got uh now he there is
no yeah there is no uh there is no doubt
that his fight is
well he's losing the fight against his
hair loss right yeah he's thinning up
top
um they're dancing around and it's uh
honestly how hard uh would it be if if
every dude if if
like who's announcing these fights uh
john hannick maybe bisping
paul felder all three of them
so that so just so chris you see the guy
on the right in the black shorts yeah
he's from he's from dagestan okay and
dagestan is slowly slowly taking over
everything oh really in fighting yes now
you made up a place dagestand so uh
that's a great company that's right
that's where khabib's from it's it's
it's it's it's somewhere
it's it's
by john
you go through a wardrobe right and then
you get to a lion and you can actually
ask it questions and he tells you where
dagestan is yeah that could be right
right right right yeah but dagestan is
near azerbaijan kyrie
made it up
um and they uh are uh very very strong
they're the toughest
oh dude so hit so the the guy who fights
on the i think he might be after this
right shin magmadov him and khabib grew
up together and
sorry marcus as kids they went growing
up as kids children of calvin doing this
yeah they would carry rocks and go up
the mountain yeah
just for the fighting is like their
national sport right so you're playing
rabbis with your brother it is they're
taking goats they're putting them on
their backs they're the hardest crazy
man and then suck in this goat what yeah
dude
no no the
um they are the hardest people on this
so i'm trying to tell you don't let
calvin fight yeah because that's his
competition
these kids are eating grass yeah it's
crazy
it's actually crazy um but you have you
have dan hooker over maka jeff
just because i liked it i'm super biased
the chance of him winning is not good
but i got it my chef will be the next 55
pound 100 i don't know how you're saying
i don't know how you deal with it how do
you deal with it i mean you're a coach
he hasn't put it together yet fully oh
yeah like josh thompson trains him he's
known him forever he's like in the
training room he's the best i've ever
seen he's like so what you guys are
seeing right now in the ufc he just like
when it's a main event he just hasn't
lived up to his potential yet right once
he puts it all together because he's a
better striker than could be jesus he's
you know his wrestling uh grappling not
as good but still a 10. could be just an
11. good game but his striking is
superior to khabib's
where where did he learn striking aka or
just ak started in dagestan uh starred
dexter yeah his his coach was also could
be where is this guy uh
on kalev train out of
uh
like chris edward narnia
narnia with the lion that's crazy he
misspelled venom on the back of his
shorts
it says venom yeah in a cool way
because they're like you're into merch
yeah i have
okay don't be cocky and don't do that
are you gonna flex on brian right now
it's just
it's cute when you say that okay man i'm
into merch talk to me in a normal boy or
is it the
people that are into
my merch talk to me in a normal voice
and don't be condescending okay okay
okay all right yeah i i just i don't
take that vein in your your torch is
still going with it merchant's still
going well
hey you guys oh god damn it chris it's
it's going well yeah
yeah the guys
yeah yeah yeah it's it's going well all
right dude okay fine dude that's how
people are right
that's how those business guys are how
are things it's uh it's it's going good
it's it's not it's
how are you doing busy
i almost wore my merch today but it's
just should have man yeah this bothers
me ask me how how things are going how
are things going having a lot of fun
it's going that bad huh that was always
the thing in acting whenever you'd ask
in la when things are not going well it
would always start with they'd always
answer in a really weird way like how's
it going yeah no things are uh i got a
couple projects
yeah no
man here we go
so this is not the
th this is the fight before the main one
no there'll be five fights yeah but
they're all like killer fighters
i honestly haven't
i mean he's a beast
he lost his last fight and then they
give him this monster yeah i'm not doing
any favors i watched a few uh i watched
maybe the last two um ufc's yeah with
your girl or what yeah um
oh that guy who i mean that guy got beat
the [ __ ]
but kept going awful uh that was uh
brian uh
yes ortega and i i was i said they
should stop that fight when he said one
finger two he said two
after that
you know it really pissed me off that
guy's too tough for his own good he's
two i
uh set him up with vr goggles so yeah so
you can learn to figure out how he can
learn and he's it's very intense for him
he cries but it's like hey dude that's
what he did he's got to get through it
yeah
he's got to get through it right and he
does no after i take dude when i take
the vr guy guys off five hours later he
five hours he gets all the fights
so he he's going down yeah he cries for
him you know they do say that children
who watch it their cortisol levels go up
and all that oh dude if i put these
fights on right now because boston grew
up watching it yeah he's two he'll go
like this nice well your kids are your
kids are built for war yeah your kids
are different they're they're built for
sport and for combat they are
tiger lost his tooth last night woke up
crying was like dad get my tooth out the
the money maker yeah silent all right
you look like a hockey player so at two
in the morning i pulled the tooth out
he's like just and he's crying i'm like
dude this is great news the tooth fairy
comes now you get money he's like really
daddy don't have any cash so the tooth
fairy gave him a 50 gift certificate to
starbucks
and he goes so he wakes up this morning
goes dad what is i thought i was getting
cash i go just because cash dude
tooth fairy tooth fairy's been working
non-stop i didn't have time to get cash
you little [ __ ] so here's 50 in star
buttons you like the the cake pops just
as good there you go cake pops are good
that's he was [ __ ] hilarious you know
what you should have done that's a bit
yeah you should have done
when he said dad
i got the starbucks gift card what the
heck you should have flipped your
[ __ ]
lids
and you've been like
you aren't great you're joking right
and then he goes no look and you say let
me see that and then and then you go
like this
[Laughter]
the next tooth you lose
i'm going to wait up with a shotgun
and when i see that tooth fairy
i'm going to blow her [ __ ] brains out
he's five soldiers
he's five bro
he's five
i don't know if that's good dude see
this is why honestly i think you guys
yeah are bad dads no we're not hey and
you need to understand how to teach
yourself you let your kid fight on
lessons no i do keep my son away from
his mother that's what the spartans did
and he does sleep out he sleeps on a
marble slab and he eats from a bowl of
gruel yes face down on a marble yes and
he will train he will train um today's
puke day he runs hills
but he's 10. he's 10 so he's already
so that guy's too bloody
god he's getting beat up pretty wild
in dagestanians they have like a
distinct look don't they yeah just not
much of a forehead yeah beard they don't
see not a lot of male pattern ball in
the state they seem to have very good
hair lines scary and just tough tough as
[ __ ] well their nose has been broken
their nose was already broken and yeah
look at his nose my friend's son
uh wrestled in azerbaijan for the moment
five
and the way they train the way they
wrestle and the way they train is you'd
get shut down you'd get shut down in the
united states yeah yeah so how about
the guy who fights net next hamza comes
at daddy before he was in the ufc
remember conor was talking [ __ ] to
khabib and some other guys about being
dagestanian
he had he was like 1-0 he wasn't in the
ufc he flew to [ __ ] ireland to find
conor and beat him up because he
disrespected why
this is coms out the guy who got the guy
who fights next yes he got covered right
right right right right yeah yeah
but he flew to ireland to just to whoop
his ass he was like i was just gonna go
to his gym he would eventually get that
beat the [ __ ] out of him yeah for
disrespect and uh dagestan yeah he got
stopped by
uh police officials at the airport they
could they contained him for i think he
said seven hours didn't feed him or
anything i was like you gotta get back
on the plane and then he flew him back
because he lives in sweden they flew him
back she flew him back flew them
there you go take down take down chris
inside trip take it so there are the
other brain busters chris gets right
back up though by the way look at his
leg look at look at doug uh
on a club's back of his leg he's been
taking some leg
oh yeah this guy's got some ham hocks on
him yeah big strong guys it's crazy when
their [ __ ] hamstrings pop out like
that like biceps you know what i mean
yeah it's crazy when their hamstrings
pop out like biceps
uh
yeah they were
these guys are wow they're really going
aren't they
did you did you ever hear did you ever
hear you know how john hank has to do it
and like when it's like the prelims he
has to give like backstory to some of
the guys yeah
before i say this there's nobody that i
love more than jonathan he's so good but
he's you know he's trying to fill there
and he's like yeah uh you know i forget
the guy's names like robertson domestic
violence case going on
yeah and it's all quiet in here
so anyways he's 3-0 in the ufc you can
hear the whole broadcast like okay and
anik is so good man i don't know how
they do that
dude vin scully used to do it alone with
the at the dodgers like with the dodgers
yeah yeah baseball though you know yeah
well that's there's more down time yeah
exactly yeah but you have so many guys
like batter you know next month oh right
you're just talking about one guy here
we go yeah but still at least there's
actually four last series against the
reds
yeah to be that knowledgeable is [ __ ]
crazy though like not panic right it's
just like yeah well that's crazy
especially this car especially this card
[ __ ] so many guys from russia and
dagestan and europe so the names are
look at the names
yeah i know what those are but honestly
how does but annika never fought how
does he get to be
he just came up with so good or what
he's just how do you understand he
started on espn he's just like those
guys are special good the guys
yeah all those guys on espn those those
they because they started a lot of times
i wouldn't say all writers but a lot of
all of them like a lot of them who
started out as sports writers they just
know sports you know smith started
sports yeah that's what i know started
i think it was uh i think it was
chicago i think he started in chicago or
philly a lot of those guys skipped
something he started in dallas he was
the cowboys good writer
good writers yeah and then they have
personalities and they're [ __ ] oh
look at his eyebrow
oh damn jesus christ hey being in boxing
they'd stop that fight right no no it's
not bleeding into that oh [ __ ] dude
check hook
oh [ __ ] it just splits open could there
be a tougher way to make a living it's
so hard dude and then chris you'd quit
there because what would you do with
calvin when he's done
yeah or i would just be like
you know dude ship them to austin and
ship them to rogans see what wrong you
doing ship them
but honestly like you know these guys
these guys haven't been older yet you
know what i mean what do you mean like
like these guys just get knocked the
[ __ ] around like there's nobody the ufc
is relatively young like when these guys
are 70 yeah
it could be a time you saw what happened
you know what i mean you saw what
happened to muhammad ali it's just like
yeah yeah you know i don't know if you
guys know muhammad ali was like one of
the greatest
uh boxers box is a different sport yeah
it is a different sport and you're right
but he took a lot of yeah it is it is a
bit in its infancy as well it's like
major sports yeah but you're seeing more
and more like you'll see some guy you
know i'm not saying we see some like
hall of famers where you're like yeah
yeah that's how this ends yeah i know
it's like like uh coleman was like yeah
i need a hip replacement well that's not
good you die if you break your hip
you're dead yeah
no that's not you're dead nope no you're
dead no you dropped me you drink
mcdonald's coffee huh yeah i used to you
and i used to be close and then yep
okay that separates us a little bit okay
why huh no no you know what let me get
this straight why not do this let me
give you the straight okay you pull up
to mcdonald drive-thru in a ferrari i
have and order the coffee
yeah
have you varied your diet or do you
still eat only uh dude i'm saying white
bread turkey i don't eat white bread i
actually did eat white bread i like but
i don't eat white bread that much yeah
what do you what do you eat i eat a lot
of you know bowls rice bowls
dude you know
yes asking a question you know i eat
have you checked have you checked to see
if you're malnourished no dude i'm just
a certain color because i'm built
different okay have you got any more
tats
no but i want oh no but i got one coming
up do you think your face is getting
your back it's gonna be surprising what
is it on your back no i'm not even going
to tell you what's on your secret not
telling you where not telling you what
because people don't i don't i hate when
people make something that's not amazing
i don't know where my tattoos are
when i get it you got to
but i'm not going to tell you what i'm
going to do and when i do it
you know get my dates tattooed to your
back dude the thing is
then the dates will pass and they won't
be for promotion anymore
that's a stupid idea but just as a this
is the guy
no dude i'll give you you should get my
name tattooed because i've been such an
influence
dude comedically
no look at me no no look at me i'm
looking at you
i'm not getting your [ __ ] hey
did you take your workshop
he did you did you used to study me not
a day went by that you weren't in the
back like this when i was riding
just [ __ ] pulling [ __ ] out you and
dove
yeah yeah and he'd be like this
learning i don't make that i don't hear
him i heard somebody at the waitress
said do you know what he was doing and
he was going like this
no i don't say papa when you're on stage
well you used to when i was your
teacher no you're not i was your
guru no
don't say guru yeah i was your
guru
no you were the mama bird bee yeah he
called me sensei for a long time i
didn't you did under your breath
sometimes
i don't i shouldn't be tired this is
nothing i shouldn't this is unfair to do
that he would come to me like this with
his hands like that why because you just
you needed me to fill your hands with
knowledge
i don't know how
i have this drunk girl thing but i don't
know how to do it
that was a while ago dude that was a
while ago you have uh coasters for your
own [ __ ] yeah yeah pretty good you've
heard of espn right bro it's not hey hey
you've heard of worldwide of sports i
mean honestly no i haven't heard of that
really yeah i know espn but have you
heard of nbc
i'm just i've heard of nbc dude i worked
for them for a long time so yes i know
and you know it's like a network yeah i
get it dude
this is the thick boy
hey hey chris it's annoying it's called
dick point network dude
i wanted to be called
i wanted to be initials or something
espn nbc your face is so turned off you
want me to call it tbn yeah dickboy
network tbn we can call it tbn
hi uh brandon child for tbn
do you own any thick boy merch
oh you know do i own any i don't know
but i would like to have some yeah but
i'm not i'm not thick do people wear it
and they're not thick oh yeah really
that's a lifestyle dude take your stick
don't say it's one thing it's a
lifestyle hey thick
it's in the heart oh
i
gotta
go
hey man let him just be let him let him
market his stuff dude hey no hey it's
just that's what he's doing a lot of
people in the heart thicknesses
and he'll get drawn in it's hard to
resist but it is it's right here
where it's in the heart
yeah ah here's what happened dude yes
have you seen dune when they did you see
dune yet no no no i won't either oh dude
how come and i think midnight mass that
series is overrated i'll fight
one of my favorite people in the world
and to see her she's so good one of my
favorite she's amazing
i did it
i wanted to talk about dune but it's all
good
no we haven't seen it all right have you
seen speakers
oh so yeah so in dune
there's like a voice that you can do
like he says like can you pass me the
water and she's like use the voice and
then he goes like
bust me the water and and she just goes
tomorrow and gives him the water that's
what that thick boy thing is yes yeah
don't do that i'm sorry anyway dude
sorry that would have been a much better
joke had you not broken off into
everything netflix has [ __ ] streamed
into the past [ __ ] three months
you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
hey hey hucks hey
hey that's where i draw the line dude
don't call me a [ __ ] disrespect that's
[ __ ] disrespectful no no no no no but
it turns me on a little bit
you haven't watched me again i have not
i know i saw squid game i saw squid game
what do you think it's good yeah it's
good yeah it is
it's it's it is good but it's crazy to
me the the the
the madness around yeah it really is
stereo really is yeah it's good though
i'm not not no hate i just i'm shocked
it's so [ __ ] big i i i thought it was
really well done
yeah yeah yeah and if i hear brian say
one more time dude the way it's shot
wait you love it i love you i thought it
was i surprised that you're a big fan of
koreans oh they make some good [ __ ]
they're great
i like their culture i like it yeah no
horror
bro
you don't want to talk to me about
korean horror films i know i know my way
right now
so you're going to be all good
have you seen jen that's a that's a
that's a well-known one sure yes
hey you know that's like you're back in
like a conversation
it's not exactly a deep cut
yeah chin give them some other ones
you know what brennan
yes that's good okay
man you're being so condescending like a
real estate agent
what are your favorite korean
uh
horror films um uh
there's i i don't know
i honestly don't know what the [ __ ] i
thought you guys i don't know
korean names
no but you speak just honestly asians do
horror way
yeah it's like legit although i will say
um i saw the ring uh american version
and then i saw the ring
what you saw the ring
yeah yeah
no but my point is the american version
is better i think everyone's like you
got to see the other did you see the
grudge though yeah it's scary yeah the
new one's way better this could be the
the american new one oh there it is yeah
it's good oh way more scary a new new
one yep that guy is the biggest head in
the world yeah it's the biggest i've
ever seen now he's fine that's a guy
that flew to uh uh ireland to fight
conor mcgregor
the tall one yeah uh another documentary
i mean you know
just rough oh christ that's crazy
yeah these guys are
uh they're fighting today yeah right
right now don't get me it's a great
fight did we bet on this chin dude no we
should though i think we do we it's
coming on a better bottle of whiskey of
choice
or money all right how much money all
right 500 500 oh hold on are you are you
taking jingling i got legion he's so
like uh he's an underdog but i'm still
taking no i can definitely see him
winning
500 contracts nightmare comes out
tonight i know but we but here's the
thing and i heard the espn like
you know guys the gambling experts yeah
like calms out but so you got to
remember he hasn't fought in a [ __ ]
year that's true yes he did
struggle with kovacs yeah so we don't we
have no idea so for him to be a minus
whatever 500 is insane yeah
because at the end of the day those guys
don't [ __ ] know that's neither do i
it's a [ __ ] [ __ ] this comes out from
chechnya or is he from dagestan i think
he might be from chechnya let me look it
up real quick just in case i'm with
chris on this i feel like he made it up
made it up
comes up
he is
such a nightmare
fight's not up that yet though you know
do people know the guy didn't show up
did you say why to people because
remember that josh oh sorry uh
yeah josh thompson's not here
he's sick not coveted he just had like
flu cold light symptoms and he has to
fly to dublin to work the bellator card
he's like dude i don't wanna fly to la i
gotta get over the sickness so he's
gonna be on next saturday the next uh
calabasas oh he wasn't even in l.a no i
have a flies in from san jose i have but
he's on everyone that's like how come
you have
a 747 tattoo hey talk about being a road
dog tell them tell them
about life so i travel a lot for
stand-up comedy jet setter
and so i got a plane
on my wrist on my well that's on my
wrist is there anything worse than uh
telling people why you get the tattoo
but i mean yeah i mean
it's personal i know but it's like you
know it's like one of those model
airplanes that you have as a kid yeah
and you have a tattoo dear [ __ ] it's
also spared airline plane which drives
me nuts yeah whatever i told him give me
the spirit
i want that spirit dude make sure the
plane that you put on my forearm is a
plane where the seats don't go back i
said that's yeah and he goes spirit
airline yeah you got it do not touch me
dude
you got a really strong you have strong
physical boundaries i try to do yeah
well i'm trying to do the [ __ ] voice
um
yeah does that you talk to your son do
you do do you think are you gonna make
me drink by myself oh i'm sorry but also
hey you're sober huh
i don't drink yeah hey
well okay guys i mean don't make me
don't pressure me and you come in here
with me
dude this coffee is good for mcdonald's
mcdonald's i mean i would never eat did
you get a [ __ ] mcflurry no dude i
don't eat that [ __ ] [ __ ] i don't you
just get the coffee yeah that's it i
don't you don't like you don't like to
make riddles come on hey hey hey
honestly hey
listen hey can i say you don't like the
hashbrowns
i like the hash browns i'm not saying i
don't biscuit sandwich yeah
hey chris who [ __ ] went um dude
homer's here
[Laughter]
biscuits dude
i uh i don't uh oh oh they're gonna kiss
what dana's looking thick huh i went
down dana's looking very thick he went
down
he goes down hey
you may grill it dude
of course it's good it's engineered to
be good you let calvin eat it
no i don't want him to eat it but
sometimes what's wrong with you well i
mean yeah every now and then he
can i say a sentence without you [ __ ]
all right sorry man sorry
guys dude he he eats it sometimes i know
that kristen sometimes is like driving
around you know just [ __ ] like and
she's like i gotta get [ __ ] you gotta
get a feeling before i get it yeah and
that's fine i don't want to be a [ __ ]
nazi about it you know what i mean you
don't want the weird kid
mcdonald's again like i'm not yeah yeah
yeah but i'm not gonna eat that [ __ ]
you're better than calvin do you think
you're better no i don't think i'm
better than calvin but i'm not going to
eat
do you eat mcdonald's you don't even
need [ __ ]
yeah this guy's a youth i did the other
day though i went to the airport and i
had a
taco bell no no i had a i was the
airport i had hash browns and i had a uh
uh mc mcmuffin [ __ ] delicious i know
it's so good it's [ __ ] delicious the
best i got
[ __ ] postmates cinnabun at 10 o'clock
last night you pieces cinnamon wow
you're a little bit of a fat kid at
night when the sun goes down that's
where you get turned into
i'll tell you right now i don't like
cinnabons
yeah because you're very disciplined all
through the year i don't
it's too much
it's too much dude you know you can get
just the middles with icing now i will
fight you yeah you don't like cinnabun
it's a little bit much too much
you put it in your mouth and you go
where am i yeah it's too much i put in
my mouth like you know this is heaven
you can eat and then i and then i and
then i forgot myself to throw up after
it listen dude
you don't have an overwhelming sense of
that's way too sweet yes no
okay
no i will say this i like the way you're
reacting but i disagree i like that you
are standing your ground
but i disagree really
if i had a box of them do you think you
could eat all of them in a sitting for
real bro like this like this yes
and they're done like the kool-aid man
dude really cookie monster it and it had
how do you feel afterwards terrible fine
and i ride my bike for 40 miles wow wow
do you know that they say if you have
lots of muscle glycogen you use the
glycogen your muscles actually shut up
thanks chris
shut up dude but i just that's boring is
[ __ ] all get out dude come on let me
speak let me be glycogen well look over
at me first of all dude hey glycogen is
[ __ ] boring to talk about dude hey
let me tell you something i'll look at
you but when i turn my head
you better be in a lab coat
because you're talking about glycogen
now
if you're not in a lab coat
you have to stop talking
would you look at that
hey
this is chris one time [ __ ] glycogen
hey this is chris it's me rogan it's
just a bunch of comics at the comments
we're just sitting around in the parking
lot i started talking and i said one
thing i go well historically
hey chris goes oh jesus christ here's
brian ready it is boring brian again ah
i'm brian science science
you're history history
anti-intellectual nah i'm [ __ ]
intellectual bro say one intellectual
thing
okay go ahead
one book you've read dagestan
dude
let's
okay
i don't know if that's
i don't know if that's [ __ ]
very uh
500 on this geno yeah let's do it five
this is the one i like chin i like where
you're going with this i like your
loyalty or well he's chinese he's
chinese this guy's relaxed he's asian
though this guy shaves his underarms
relaxed
this guy shaves his heart
this guy's very very shaved hey uh
russia would be considered
asia uh right um
it would be considered eurasia
eurasian anywhere at l.a eurasia
but then also downtown is pretty asian
it's super asian yeah and then also
orange county orange county so anywhere
in l.a yeah yeah but but it's but it
would be technical you could technically
say that but i would say it's it's
considered the arrangement or you know
chris
because it's connected oh this dude's a
[ __ ]
warrior
he is a [ __ ]
warrior like a bad guy from big trouble
in little china huh dude he's no joke
he's clearly similar he's such a beast
he's a migrant
but
now how tall are these guys five four no
no they look small no these guys are
actually he's probably not a star he's
probably about
if you were sitting next to him you'd go
oh this guy's losing like yeah yeah oh
really
well i know china but that specific part
oh i don't know but they're i think
they're teammates i'm going to say he's
near by the way look this up i think
he's near in the gobi desert i think
he's from mongolia i think he's from
that party yep because uh homeboy raped
so many people right he spread his seed
yes uh [ __ ] uh um genghis khan
i know that mongolia no chris he's
[ __ ] lineage
he raped so many people he spread his
seat mongolia though uh they have
wrestling they have uh they're they're
big wrestlers in mongolia brian tell
chris how they survived on horses they
were the first dude
i don't want to know i already i've
learned that and i let it [ __ ] leave
my brain i don't need to know that put
it back together you know do you know
how the do you know on long trips how
the mongols survived when they were with
the horses what did they do [ __ ] yeah
dude what'd they do tell them they eat
tell them what did they [ __ ] eat dude
whatever the postmates was back then
okay no that's not
correct
it's close but it's not correct you take
another guess
i don't know i just know that they
couldn't track it while it came to them
because there was no phones no they
would drink their horse's blood they
would tap a vein and they would need
mare's milk
and blood and they would from they would
mix it well you know what i do not know
this that's not good that's not good no
that they did that they shouldn't have
done that and you know how i know
they're all [ __ ] dead now okay
fair point
fair point yeah well this
what what does it say does it say he's
from what part of china
originally same part as uh i'm going to
say the kobe didn't serve from the same
problem not sure but it says
xinjiang china but but brian you said
this got up but brian you said
that this guy's thick he looks lean as
[ __ ] he's lean he's not big but his
head's thick yeah he's he's lean but i i
when he's probably not training he
probably goes up to 190 195 yeah but
still i wouldn't say it's thick
look at him so different parts of china
zhang whaley and uh other different
different parts but i'm sure they're i
remember they were like teammates or
they they know each other really well
hey you know what's weird is how we have
all these issues with china right and
then the winter olympics is in beijing
and then we all gotta go then pretend
everything's all good like they're not
taking hong kong as slaves and [ __ ]
on the uyghurs
what would you call me the weakness call
me a wigger yes no i'm saying the wheels
that's offensive the weakers are they're
muslim
who are in at least
yeah at least dude ers guys
wow look at this look at him talking now
he's excited this is gonna be so awesome
this is great minus 600 is insulting yes
he's not my 600. i would give him uh
minus 200.
because we have no idea he's been out
for a [ __ ] year he's been fighting
his whole life look at him this is where
he belongs let's take it easy he's
excited
he's excited and that's what i do you
know what's weird i was watching the
embeddeds and the weigh-ins there not a
ton of people came out
um like to those like you know in vegas
or wherever like atlanta for say like
it's packed but it is that that jazz
island area so it's got to be you got to
fly in from wherever yeah it's weird
though right like yeah and i was
watching them do their open workouts
like jesus chris there's nobody there
chin can you locate on a map what town
where he's from what province i'm gonna
tell you it's close to that guy's my
first ref in the ufc is that right yep
herzog is he what's his background how
do you become a ref you train
i think you just like fill out some
paperwork and then you're you're there
does that happen all brian
what's happening the touching process
yeah i'm right perfection i believe
that's in the kobe does drive here we go
china i want 500 cash daddy because my
kids oh damn you took him down oh yeah
because when my kid's tooth falls out i
need cash
also just go to the atm take it down
because now you're dealing dude
most places
out that's way better graphics oh
there's a little uh uh oh my god oh yeah
that kid that would have been viral
alrighty right now he might be four oh
he's always older he's like 40. oh wow
he's been he's not that old
he's like 18 or not 47 years is that
true actually he's 18 or 19 yeah
he didn't get a star but he's super
famous now bro
i don't know if his teeth fell out yet
fear
um
look at him he looks mad yeah he looks
mad he's [ __ ] pissed the kid he
should be happy is he hums that's
winning is that true that he's 18 or 19.
yeah brian
okay i thought he was 40. he said it
he wasn't he supposed to fight chin
that was like i think it was a running
joke i'm not sure if he was actually
going to be well he would lose he's
going to be well no he's going to fight
another smaller dude
same kind of condition
how do you get him off you'd be look at
this he's just he's just it's a
nightmare look at his hips and just i
know if it's gonna be this then hanzo is
gonna win for sure okay i guess let's
see because he's not you know damn look
at those sounds look at that handsome
[ __ ] on the left
dude is that louis
dude just [ __ ] jesus christ that
guy's
from dubai you know how rich those
saudis oh dude yeah but bro that guy
[ __ ] prunes for sure
oh so it's paul felder oh it's d.c
he's just dude look at those sounded god
i wish oh that's bad
that guy's tough as [ __ ] right on the
left
yeah it would it be cultural
appropriation if i wore that saudi
outfit uh is that frowned upon
people were everything
chris
hey chris i don't know if you know this
hey dude hey just hear me at what i'm
selling phobes that say life rips ooh
that'd be cool i'll buy one is that
offensive hey i'm a lord though you're
what a lord so christian see what he's
doing now chris he's flattered you're
not a lawyer
he's just gonna okay well i don't really
understand what
i the [ __ ]
almost done it's almost done you can't
stop it you can't defend himself that's
a nightmare he's so [ __ ] up you can't
get him off you oh you know what they
say they say this isn't even a ounce of
how talented he is oh god he's no no
one's been able to push him no they oh
here we go
it's over
god dude he didn't get off dude you uh
[ __ ] lead and get a punch off oh he's
winking he's winking at him hold on
let's see
who's winking
in there oh this is [ __ ] tough
it's over it's over well what
how did he not sync it yet honestly
it's over but wait let me hold on hold
on just look at this i don't know how
he's like passing out yeah that's what
i'm saying god damn how is he not
passing out oh
damn i thought it was gonna be a
striking match that's good too wait a
minute give me 500 i'll give you 500
bucks don't worry oh man so he was that
was fun to watch dude he was just going
to pass out the [ __ ] up no he passed out
look he's still out yeah you want to try
it yeah he no but i'm saying he wasn't
going to tap hey once right no
i've had it i've done it
you know i trained you trained
didn't you
yeah i did yeah chris if chris gets into
something he's in here yeah i know but
he never got back are you still buying
kicks
still buying kicks nonstop
i stopped because of the pandemic it was
like i'm not you're not wearing them
anywhere bro you know i want those oh
damn it talk about the mummies yeah i'm
talking about those yeah so annoying
they sent me these earlier all right who
by the way by the way
you may as well just hand comes out the
[ __ ] belt now for 85. he's gonna beat
him well oh oh no first of all he's 70.
hey dude is there stuff to eat 77.
yeah dude i catered we got nashville
chicken hot sandwiches when you get done
yeah but you only get it if you're funny
[Laughter]
that's crazy because he was fighting at
85.
who is that 70 right yeah who is running
who's running the show
what happened
the
nightmare yeah the nigerian nightmare
shout out to krishna koi oh you know
what now who went to azusa pacific i
know chris nakoya the nigerian who do
you play for
uh he was uh come on daddy
west
rival of my broncos ran over steve
atwater steve atwater ran over steve
atwater played for the
giants
that's right the chiefs the giant chiefs
all right guys this holiday season
shout out to manscape the global leaders
and blow the belt grooming the manscape
performance package 4.0 chris as i like
to call it the perfect package for your
package this holiday season give the
gift that keeps on giving and keeps your
bush trimmed all right with this perfect
performance package you get a lawnmower
4.0 trimmer a weed whack for your ears
and nose crop preserver ball deodorant
all right don't let your balls get all
stinky they got a crop reviver toner
yeah dude we got boxers in there a
little travel bag you put it all
together we got you covered man listen
it has an led spotlight so when you're
when you're in the dark you want to
shoot you meant by that yeah you can do
it in the night
yeah no in my eyes i have night vision
oh wow but but that's cool because he
eats a lot of carrots
all right we'll get 20 off in free
shipping by going to manscape.com cfc
that's 20 off and free shipping by going
to manscape.com
cfc be thankful this holiday season for
the best gift of all from my friends at
manscaped your balls will thank you
i did that again kids back um [ __ ]
rock yeah don't be mad at my reading
skills no well it's not hey i've worked
on it no you hate
hey what do you mean you've worked i
worked on it dude i like your reading
skills thanks dude
hey i worked on it okay can you explain
that please sure you just read more okay
can you say it out loud so that's
because i have to do 25 reads a week
dude okay so you've worked on
reading or s or or the way out loud oh
okay i understand yeah dude he had a
little speech thing going on okay
all right dude
i'm not bullying no it sounds like he's
bullied no i'm not dude i'm not a
bullying
speech impediment i don't i think i
didn't even know you had a speech better
i just thought you always had cupcakes
in your mouth oh my man you're that good
cupcakes or cinnabons in his cheeks no
man that's what i thought that's not
what you thought you would be sorry
you're not
i'm gone okay but don't
okay apologize for that i don't sorry i
don't i'm sorry i'm truly sorry thank
you i'm sorry and i also i'm sorry that
i thought no that lamp was from the
middle ages
that's a tiffany lamp shane have you
ever heard of tiffany
shane hey you ever heard of nbc
have you ever heard of
change it you've heard of like fox news
yeah dude i've heard of fox news this is
tbn
[Laughter]
you are going gray yeah i am i am we all
got grace
funny coming from you well i just i just
appreciate that my friends are getting
older and catching up to me i i can't
wait dude i
i can't wait until however many years it
takes i walk in and i'm [ __ ] like
that guy from the virgin airlines guy or
whatever the [ __ ] richard i'm gonna grow
it out i'm gonna you know what i'm gonna
do get [ __ ]
white contact lenses oh let me see dude
i'm going to be looking you look like a
white walker yeah bro and i'm going to
do comedy like that
and people are going to be like i don't
know it's kind of distracting but in the
thick of my [ __ ] act when i stop and
i say
it doesn't matter i'm prepared to die
tonight they understand do you
understand they understand now i had to
dig deep in my memory to remember what
that saying was
but i got it
because i'm a professional it's called a
callback and i do call backs yeah and
when i do yeah they hit you like that
wave in deep impact that comes and hits
the [ __ ] dad and daughter
that's
what happens i feel like do you remember
that movie i i do do you know why i
stored it in my brain
just in case i needed it okay and now
was the time okay because
i'm a professional okay you know i've
never said that before you have but now
i have okay chris
and i will say
you're welcome no i'm going to clip this
part
put it on instagram okay so the world
can see you know you're actually i'm a
professional no you're acting like a
messiah you're you have a messianic
complex admit that so in doom
[Laughter]
unbelievable
you're you're being you're being
grandiose and very very you're turbo
arrogant right now you need to dial it
down
a little bit do be hum say something
with humility okay be humble say
something that makes us realize you're
actually humble okay say one thing i
will yes so
this is the thinnest my wallet has been
in a long
[Laughter]
that is time humble no i thought it was
one of the coasters and i go oh it's not
but yeah it's usually yes it yes it is
it's a gucci wallet right yeah that's a
gucci with a snake on it and you're
saying well it just usually doesn't fold
right right
because you're not
it's too thick is that where you're no
because of his merch no right the so the
yes life rips [ __ ] make friends in
the comments [ __ ] well you know you
know it's like no
you know what i mean
[Laughter]
this [ __ ] usually [ __ ] like a pops
like a booby trap right but
yeah
you went late today yeah
yeah did you did you train this morning
or you just wake up
we're all out of bed is this early for
you oh yeah oh it's seven
oh it sucked waking up because you're a
night guy yeah well i'll tell you why
this place it's too far
it's uh we're we're
calabasas is awesome if you take a nice
drive though if you take i i i go pch i
love it yeah i like it hairless eight
minutes from here but
now um
that's rose namajunas
and she's phenomenal that is and she has
the lord that's is that fight next shin
is that no not on this card is that next
week it should be next week
the card next week stacks
wow
this is just
so these these women can they beat the
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of you yes
yeah no
my uh my speed my cunning my fight iq
my
yeah
you know what happens i go like this oh
i know you i know what you watch me i i
know what you want chris what i bet you
watched logan paul's fight oh i watched
it yeah yeah
now he's excited mike tyson can i get
your oh i actually have thoughts on all
this boxing [ __ ] that's going on and uh
with like the youtubers and the reason
well the youtubers yeah it
honestly if you're taking it as
seriously as logan paul and [ __ ] uh
jake paul then you know they deserve a
chance to box right i mean but like it's
clearly a market for it they're making
millions right no i understand that
you're also training hard for it but
even that though i you know i think if
there's a market for it who gives them
yeah i agree
yeah but it's no one's watching it's
like what do you do but it's well if
it's but but but my question is and i
don't know much about it but like
the it's really [ __ ] irresponsible
irresponsible is that the word not
irresponsible right
no but thank you i appreciate general
general chain around your neck but yeah
yeah
so uh so that is general so wait what's
what you're saying you're saying so all
you're talking about
isn't it irresponsible for a guy to just
be like okay i want a box now and a year
later get in the ring and like they're
gonna [ __ ] some somebody's gonna die
they trained for three years but they're
not they are they are but some of the
guys aren't right yeah but i would say
jake and logan but the rest of the
youtubers that no one's taking seriously
they're fighting another youtuber so
it's like i know but isn't that
dangerous not really no they're those
are they they're not fighting other
professional guys so they're
like like if you and brian want to fight
that would happen well well well they
well now now though you've got logan
fighting mike tyson i'm i'm amazed at
his he's got balls
he's gutsy
imagine if imagine if calvin's logan
paul right yeah and he's whatever 23
years old he goes dad i'm going to box
i'm this big youtuber i'm going to box
and go all right cool hey and i'm going
to fight floyd mayweather and mike tyson
you'd like you're out of your [ __ ]
well floyd's
much smaller much smaller mike tyson has
the power to knock well that'd still
knock you into the next but chuck
liddell made a good point uh when he's
on food drinking now available now on uh
below
uh chuck liddell said uh he goes
he goes because i go would you fight
logan paul goes i would fight him but
it'd be a fight like i'm i'm going to
fight him i'm not going to do this
glorified yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah and he was like with mike
tyson how do you see that going down
he's it's a glorified sparring match
because tyson's not going to go crazy
well if you look at what tyson and roy
jones like that wasn't a real fight no
no they're older guys and they didn't
really hit to the house right right so
he's like i would like he was i'll watch
it but i'd love to see if tyson actually
like brought the real fight to him well
also tyson's about 55. he doesn't get a
bit of it if you but if he gets close
and he that that that's sort of like it
does matter though because if the rules
are and i'm saying these are the rules
but the rules are oh wow i know no
knockouts to the head no you know no you
know okay i didn't know they were gonna
have rules like that i don't i'm not
saying they do have rules like that but
chuck point was it's glorified sparring
like they're not trying to take each
other out he's like i'm down to do it
but i'm gonna try and take him out yeah
yeah i think uh either way but jake's
but see logan and jake are different
yeah logan's going for the biggest
payday the most views the floyd
mayweathers mike tyson's chances when
that fight's not good right so for him
just to survive as a win for him he
makes all the best
those guys
but jake's actually you know his fight
against tommy fury like tommy fury's a
real professional boxer i respect that
like tyrone woodley's an actual
professional fighter ben asking an
actual person but that's so different
than boxing isn't it well tywin
yeah that's different because he's not a
striker any faster
jake paul's serious about it and and i
respect i think you're not saying
no i i do respect that and logan paul
these guys they have a work ethic they
have that that midwest farm boy work
ethic they work their ass
and they're smart business big and
athletic and strong yeah athletic
athletes i saw logan the other day he
was at the laugh factory and and we you
know we were like hey what's up and and
he had that
like that
it was like a brand yeah you know what i
mean like when you shake a fighter's
hand
it was like uh yeah it's like a it was
really he'd keep you busy chris yeah
he'd keep you busy well if if you guys
talk i don't want to fight dude you know
what i mean
what would you say
what are you saying i went on a show i
was like dude you would love him yeah
did he do it no we were butts he he uh
but that was just jokes and honestly i
uh you know
it was fun yeah it was but you know a
social media beef
yeah it's not real what do you say
before you fight a man me yeah
i i uh
i just laugh a lot you do i laugh a lot
yeah i laugh i kick back i laugh so hard
if somebody wants to fight me i'm
because i know
it's not going to be good for the guy
right it's not going to be no and i
don't mean like i may lose yeah but
we're both going to get really hurt yeah
he's going to remember you yeah so i go
i laugh i'm you know i i i
just crying and then i get my blazer on
and i fight
i fight with a blazer on you don't you
like a gentleman yep just a blazer
okay yep good
night yeah
nice
i think if any fights you're sorry to
break that up i think if any fights can
go decision it's going to be this
i wish i would die
i brought a big bowl of [ __ ] pasta
and just ate it while you're doing this
no no no i don't even mean about hungry
it would be so awesomely respectful that
i was doing what i wanted in front of
you guys oh okay
i just feel like a pasta just a big i'm
talking about nice know it'd be more
disrespectful a giant ham
just a big ham and you look like it's
going no big time
like a big thing up just crunching in
the in the mic yes yeah and just didn't
give it any to you a leg of mutton just
a big piece of mutton yeah
yeah yeah
i really [ __ ] up not doing that what's
your last meal
the last one you're not a food guy so
what would be your favorite food is he a
food guy no he's not i'm not i'm giving
[ __ ] about food dude you don't all right
well what do you mean i don't know
[ __ ] living he likes food you go to
[ __ ] you go to ralph's and get a
mustard and i don't know
mayonnaise dude
so that does sound nice that's good yeah
but that's that's that's that's the
simple you eat you're a creature of
habit you're on the spectrum i am so
what did you eat this morning let me
guess
overnight oats
some bread what would you have i made
it's funny you asked my my maiden let me
tell you right now it's not funny i
asked okay
i made my son and myself
buttermilk crepes
heavy on the eggs and i made a pork
tenderloin yesterday so instead of bacon
i had pork tenderloin
very very lean pork that i rubbed with
coriander
and and enough spice a proprietary spice
mix i dry rubbed it
and then i baked cnn too well no i and
then i put some maple syrup on my pork
it was [ __ ] delicious dude
that's
yeah
no i know
right i have the most boring
conversation of all time for you okay
bye
sorry dude that was guinness book
dude
that's that's super disrespectful
i was just telling you what i had you
did ask me this no i know i didn't yeah
but it started with what's your last
meal yeah yeah yeah
it was my fault yeah but yeah we're
going to be in uh the new
2022 edition of
guinness book of worlds okay
what do you guys do anything for
halloween yeah do anything with calvin
uh yeah you guys trick or treat around
the hood
you're saying all right
or you could put that hoodie up and just
be vampire
why don't you say vampire because you
you should have i can't believe you
don't have a romanian accent it's
incredible i don't even know what a
romanian accent
you talk like this
you know i'm not really i'm not a
vampire what is your nationality so i am
uh italian
[Music]
are you jewish chris
no i'm not jewish
i'm italian
i am um
irish
and polish have you done ancestry.com
but how did you get so no no
no the less male and the less clicking
boxes i have to do on the internet the
better sure i don't know but if you were
like i'm from oh yeah but if you said
i'm from slovenia and
this accent is for show business but you
actually had your real the way you spoke
really was i'm from slovenia i had to
learn how to speak like this yeah
so i wouldn't get typecast as as you
always say
the [ __ ] bad guy in the taking movies
yeah yeah and that's disrespectful and i
don't like that you say that hey look
i'm getting ice oh dude coveted city
dude
how about i kill me chris's house yeah
what last time i mean this was a long
time ago it was that high to cover i'd
give you that one we didn't know what
was going on i didn't know what it was
he made me stay six feet away from him
in his backyard outside
now let me ask you a question yeah out
of the three of us yeah who didn't get
covert all right true
hey you bubble baby yeah yeah
but uh brian almost died i no i now i
have crazy
you didn't really not you huh oh dude
don't be so cocky about he was biking he
was like 40 miles that's why carter got
better now i will say this though i did
[ __ ] with my taste buds oh we need real
strong coffee real spicy food right real
cinnabon 19 cinnabons yes
my buddy got hit his head and he lost
his taste for life how bad would that be
yeah
i would like that because i'd be scared
i'd be skinny i'd be skinnier well yeah
like i like for some here's how you know
you're actually fat is even without my
taste buds i still like pizza and and
[ __ ] chipotle burritos oh wow just in
case so yeah because i want the texture
no i want the texture yeah yeah that's a
fat [ __ ] [ __ ] for real
you you uh
night time is when you watch tv and and
eat a lot of that binge watch i've been
doing all the shows i've been doing that
when i'm really stressed i do that when
i'm really stressed
daddy eats yeah yeah i i don't know but
daddy also works out yeah so it balance
itself out yeah so i don't look like you
know butterbean right yeah so uh you eat
at night i do i thought you didn't i
don't now i do oh really yes now okay
brian tell them about nightshades no at
54 now i i do bad things man i eat ice
cream bars i eat i go crazy i know
really i really do this [ __ ] [ __ ] it my
my taco my girlfriend my girl was like
brian what you got to stop i'm i'm
eating i ate pringles
crackers
and you look exactly the same i know
that's the that's what i know it's like
if you're you're just because i tried a
guy like i don't give a [ __ ] i know you
look exactly the same i stopped working
out for a month and it didn't really i
didn't look that different and i'm like
it's so difficult
well we got different body types yeah
i'm sorry but it's okay you're handsome
you're good you have something about you
i work out a lot you don't i don't
you're it's just you could hey hey b you
could get with
[ __ ] thor i could take steroids and i
wouldn't grow some people just don't put
on muscle no well oh brian doesn't do
that you just i feel like you just don't
eat enough yeah i don't know i think
this is it's just his build that's his
dna that's what it is that's my building
twig
i'm a thin boy hey i'm going to start a
merchandise i'm going to start a merch
line called thin board t-h-i-n-n-n boy
guys i want to thank you guys for
demanding that and i'll get that merch
out dude finn boy's not part of tbn dude
come on have thin boy let's have a thin
boy branch here
good
like one room one room that's thin boy
it's real thin
yeah just a tiny room
um
you know what you
should have more merch why don't you
have more merch i don't know i'm
terrible with that stuff but i mean i
should sell it when i'm in off the
comedy club in naples november 11th to
the 14th
get your tickets
chris if you're looking to get up this
thursday friday the haha in l.a run my
30 minute before i shoot my special next
or 11th through the 13th in dallas yeah
or come down to brandon in dallas yep um
but i'm in la thursday and friday oh
where at the ha ha ha i [ __ ] love
that place so
you're shooting it in dallas where uh
addison improv oh really but the
backdrop it won't look like oh gotcha
we're building a whole set are they okay
so
so are they because
what is it a half hour specialist what
are you doing
and like okay i don't know what comedy
central does now i haven't worked with
them at a long time tell me central
you didn't it might be oh got it okay
i'm definitely gonna do that i'm gonna
do a half hour too like you said yeah in
january
so uh
and
see i like that dude thirties yeah man
it's the it's the it's the it's the it's
the way to go i don't know it's just
like it's so different now and it
changes so much well i told you when i
went literally met with netflix and i'm
like yeah no matter who it is chappelle
rogan burr
everybody stops at 28 minutes so weird
why would i give you guys an hour yeah
if we know especially my demo 1836 i'm
like why would put an hour if people are
just going to
watch 28 to 30 minutes yeah why would i
i'll just save the other 30 and put out
the following right so i'm you're
getting more
content yeah yeah instead of just
working on an hour for four years i just
like you're doing 30 every two years if
you look at guys who put stuff out on
like uh
the best is i don't mean to rep you the
best because i was telling rogan that
you know rogan's savage
dude it just 30 makes sense for me blah
blah i go like why do we do hours
because i want it
i don't know i know he goes no that's
what i want to do
that's what that's what i want to do i
like doing hours yeah
that's old school though i think half
hour makes a lot of sense
it's harder to do a half hour in some
ways because you have to be more
disciplined you got to be more you know
the fat yeah you got to cut the fat
half hour sometimes it's harder doing
shorter a shorter special is harder than
a longer special in a lot of ways i
think i think
it makes you more disciplined more
discipline you got to cut the fat and
then you got it has to be 30 minutes if
it's going to be 30 yeah
fury yeah well so you got to figure out
what to put in what to take i got that
you know that don't look you don't want
to follow that i'm going to do
a a one-minute special
oh that'd be cool just fire for a minute
fire release on tick-tock fire just a
tick-tock special yeah just
nah put on youtube yeah
just a f not even one of those what do
they have those shorts now not even that
a full fight with a crazy good intro
yeah
it's 30 minutes of intro yeah and then a
one minute special just
but but you have no idea how many jokes
did you ever see oh guys are fighting do
you ever see
maria
uh bamford she did that she did that
that that one hour special for her
parents just her parents on a house so
funny so funny dude i have nothing
special
uh i think they they all got tested as
they came in
his house yeah and for not being like
tour material and [ __ ] monster yeah i
love kevin i love it um yeah he's great
i i don't like tattoo bro but i will i
will say i don't like any specials that
are not just regular specials meaning i
just don't oh you mean like out of the
house i just think they figured out how
to do it well and and it's just and it's
just pretty straightforward and any time
you really [ __ ] with it i just feel like
it takes away from it i know people try
to get like fancy with it like yeah i
mean i don't blame them for wanting to
do something different because i i think
that that's cool and i respected it was
it gerard carmichael i could forget who
was who's the guy who's in uh get out
the black dude he's great
oh ken no how dare you uh he wrote it oh
oh do you know what i'm talking about no
no he he didn't get out he's a [ __ ] he's
like the comedy uh
scroll down literally oh yeah
did it out of a gym of like compton gym
yeah yeah yeah but that was the sound
was different but it was cool that it
was different yeah and but that wasn't
that different i mean it was a little
different but like
you know what man i called you once this
is a long time ago and i said i have an
idea for you
and you uh said i want to know what your
ideas i don't think i ever told you what
it was i think you did but my idea for
you was to do this is before netflix
yeah before netflix was a thing i said
20 years ago it was a lot it was yeah it
was like maybe 89 80 or 70. i said to
him i said i think you particularly
should do a special in front of no one
yeah you i told you that yes yeah i
remember that i i i thought that the
only person that would be able to do
that would be you 100 yeah i just think
he didn't realize the crowd's there yeah
he could yeah yeah but but i also that's
something different too like i think
joey diaz should do like a uh
the same way johnny cash did i think she
tried black and white in a prison yeah
some that's a good you know weird things
he was thinking about that actually i
think joey was thinking about doing that
it's tough it's cleared from the prisons
i think well didn't uh there's some guys
who've done it before like paul
rodriguez did it i think a long time ago
yeah yeah a couple guys joey diaz oh no
no black and white no it would be cool
yeah yeah yeah with any background
sometimes i think getting too creative
with the special itself it takes away
from it yeah i just want to see the
jokes you know that's what i learned
from from that show times just like the
state like even when i walked out like
they sent me a rendering of it on paper
and i was like well that looks cool i
just didn't know yeah i'm like god this
is distracting what is what the
background said like job
yeah brian's so funny he comes he gets
the he gets in he goes
what are you going to do with these
letters after the special
i'm putting my backyard
what do you do with it mix them up spell
something cool yeah i don't know man
yeah they were so big they're like they
were each each one was like eight foot
tall i kind of liked it but it's just
like you said it's a little bit
distracting it's a lot to live up to
but you don't want people to be looking
at that when you're doing stand up it's
not that they're like it's also
something about it where it's like a lot
to it's a it's a lot to live up to it's
like a celebration that you shouldn't be
celebrating at that moment right i don't
know right like just comedy you know
just do the comedy it was a lot it is a
lot of times we're laughing because
there's a lot you're not supposed and i
also didn't like it in a theater right
like to me like i feel my best when i'm
in like a small intimate like la jolla
yeah like addison's gonna be great like
i like the club
i like to feed off the but but i had a
thought the other day like comedies
really changed from my generation or
like as i was coming up because comedy
used to just be
like um it belonged to the guy who got
up there usually the guy
rarely the gal but the guy got up there
who was this total underdog who was
dressed shitty who just never and he got
up and he just was [ __ ] hilarious
like if you watched guys like david tell
back in the day craig geraldo oh my god
sure and i'd be in new york and i'd
watch these guys yeah and they'd just
get up and they were just these sloppy
dudes who probably didn't take care of
themselves certainly certainly would
never
in any way self-promote they were the
anti-self promotions
still that way well yeah but now now
with this new generation and people like
yourself and this is a very smart thing
is the first time that guys like you
were at this actually at the spearhead
one of the guys do this now it's schultz
and these guys
who because of the internet we're able
to not only curate an audience but make
money and create a spectacle you have
you have shorts coming out there in a in
a robe that never would have been done
back there yeah never there's bruce
buffer joe coy's got a dj that that [ __ ]
is so
almost anathema to the old school comedy
it's up in the game right like everybody
yeah well now it's a it's a show
perspective yeah yeah and then you go to
the show like and
you know everybody knows i love [ __ ]
schultz like you go to a show i'm not
just saying it's like you've never seen
anything like it like the closest one to
do it like him is kevin hart i bet
you've never seen anything like it dude
it's it's not and there's nothing it's
not
and and for him the production value
like the amount of money he spends on
production he's like oh i'm not worried
about how much money i make as long as
the fans have a great show that's all i
care about yeah because i because you
know i saw him like dude you must be you
know i know i'm like you must be
spending how much [ __ ] money a
production it's nuts yeah i'm sure it's
like a mini super bowl when you see a
show yeah i i uh
technically yeah really yeah that's so
that's so um
it's just so alien to me and no one will
leave there be like that you know that
wasn't a good show you're walking around
like holy [ __ ] remember nobody was
really making money too like it never
before the internet and podcasting even
established comics were never making tv
money some of them you know sometimes
you'd have like a like that guy rodney
they'd be making you know but but for
the most part you were doing the clubs
you were doing local and that's why
that's why guys would do stand-up to get
to tv yeah and now it's like yes if my
agent goes hey man once you do a show on
this network i'm like dude i'll make
more doing my that's right yes tv one
weekend on the road what do you think it
really does it used to be you wanted to
do a tv show to get off the road because
now
you want a road you want podcasting in
the road it better be something super
special to get you out of that that's
right
but you've been getting up uh at laugh
factory right chris different places
yeah all over mm-hmm uh did you never
answer about the ha-ha this week but
that's what oh what did you say about
the hop i said come to us oh you did it
yeah he's doing he's doing uh he's doing
improv he's emceeing no i'm not guys i'm
not doing i'm not
right up the stretch i know i'm not want
to drive down i'm not and now i'm going
to surprise everybody i'm not announcing
any shows i'm not doing anything
but i uh i do pop up yeah there's
another place called jamming vancouver
have you ever been there particularly
i don't i don't do outdoor shows it's uh
there's outdoor and there's indoors oh
you'd like jamming but why don't you do
outdoor shows you just don't like it
you'd actually like it yeah this one's
different yeah yeah no i know everyone's
gonna
invite me to do it
i was gonna do a deal the other night
yeah it doesn't feel outdoors there's
something about it i really like it is
outdoor it is outdoor
there's no roof and it's outdoor you
know how you don't let blondes in your
show i don't do outdoors yeah
interesting yeah i'm an indoor cat
no blonde guys
no blondes i don't know a lot of my
shows soy boys they're not allowed no
blondes no leather jackets no you have
leather jacket if you're brown hair oh
hell yeah but the thing is is uh you can
honestly if you're a blonde dude you can
wear a brown leather jacket but not a
black one no no
no
no no no no
no no no
have you ever worn a suit ever
do you own a suit yeah you want to see
some of the uh i wear a suit yeah i wear
a suit uh at funerals i wear a suit um
first of all don't talk like this now
you're talking like this open your mouth
[Music]
i think you have a picture you're in a
suit and i'm in a button-up at one of
your premieres years ago like [ __ ]
eight nine years ago oh i think i drove
there by myself to support my friend
chris
oh brian you weren't there no i wasn't
it was probably a [ __ ] machine gun
what's that
when you when you destroy crowds no it's
during the day
no brian does day shows oh man
mayonnaise you [ __ ] you know who
crushes day shows is uh brick crasher
you know shows in the day time i gotta
pee i'm gonna pee empire your big dick
oh i did gone in my pants
brian bring me back a [ __ ] steak
natural chicken hot sandwiches man hey
kyle where where did we uh cater the
food from um waffle
waffle love shout out to waffle love you
like nashville chicken hot sandwiches
chris hey don't never eat that
yeah and i'm not ashamed of it dude when
i say stuff i'm not insecure about it
i've never had a [ __ ] nashville hot
sandwich well here's getting just as
long as yours you just oh dude don't
make it go over the side like that i'm
little because of the reason how bad it
looks
are you you don't like emo thick that
horrid
put it back
or put the hat on nope dude that
you do look like a little nicky yep holy
fry look like avril lavigne security
wait look that way let me see how it
looks that way wow dude
avril living security
wow that's amazing yeah thanks dude i
didn't know it was that long me neither
i put in a man but you put your hair in
a man-bun
i said yeah i've never done it like no
have you done it and like gone out i've
done yeah i've done like done shows
really yeah
i'm a little self-conscious of it on
stage so i put a hat on right before i
go on dude i think you anyone should
never put do a man bun really yeah i i
don't think so just well okay it looks
sweet
well no honestly if you have really long
it looks sweet dude if you have really
long hair i don't like the way you're
sitting yeah i'm good with it though man
you know
too relaxed i'm just chill man yeah
you're a chill i'm very
i think honestly
if you have really long hair then okay
you got to put it up sometimes you're
younger than yours
way longer your hair's long is it is it
really long i mean it used to be longer
yours pretty long
let me look at it like you're just
taking a little
daddy
you know i cut my own hair
oh wow yeah so brian
whoa
but he uses a flowbee yeah it's [ __ ]
i do trims i i cut my hair and i do it
all
um you like i do kind of every now and
then i just go i walk by the mirror i go
i need to snip
and then i just the back though you're
not like
i mean you've got a couple
[ __ ] did you get long i don't even know
how to do that yeah i mean i suppose it
is layered because it's not even yeah
yeah
i'm just a you know around cool guy do
you diet you know what i don't dye it
i've never dyed my hair once i did once
i did once and every single person in my
life went don't do that again well what
did you you dyed it just for men but but
you have grace they say jet black they
mean [ __ ]
okay so one of the things online that
people say to me is
oh you dye your hair i don't eat that
stuff no well no no no but i think that
the reason is because this is gray and
this is not that they think that i dye
my hair and uh you woke up like that but
but but why
why would i dye my hair hair
and not my beard because the beard's
trickier
is it trick what do you mean it's tricky
remember what i do
yeah like brian did once look like i
took a [ __ ] marker and he's like
don't tie your beard so my friend told
me to do it i was like all right but
didn't you dye your hair too no i've
never oh well you know you did just a
beard you look like fat joe i know but
then but even when you do both you look
like an rbc you look at john b even when
you do both though
dude how he makes so much money has
somebody go well don't do that with your
beard you know what i know how bring
that up i know how this is what brian
looked like right there yeah wow look at
the box under his legs oh that's a lego
he shot his face yeah i don't know if
i'm famous enough to say something
online and have you hear it but
but that box gotta go yeah dude dj
khaled that box
fat joe that dj khaled looks so much
better on the right there does he you
look so much better like that i have
some thoughts nah dude don't lie
yeah
that looks so bad on the left
are you a
lego he looks like a leg it looks
terrible yeah it looks awesome dude it
looks like armor
dj khaled on the right that's some sexy
ass i would listen to the guy on the
right i mean look don't get me wrong
he's not good looking no no but does it
matter no you don't have to force it
does it matter you know i used to have
him i i tried this i grew i went to
italy i grew a mustache
and a little goatee
and my dad
my dad went he looked at me like i never
forgot this he looked at me he goes
what's uh this about and i said let me
do this let me picture this yeah so it's
a full mustache then like the like the
flavor saver here got this and then i
got that disgusting look just this
bubble and then that i got this and this
now my dad it was great my father goes i
came back from italy oh my father goes
what's uh this and i said i'm just
beware it now and he goes like this and
i never forgot this he goes he goes he
looked at me he goes
and i said what you don't like it and he
goes
it's not you that's fair and i and i
[ __ ] i the way he shave it right away
i shaved it immediately i went you know
for my dad to do that
like that was just it's so weird he just
whispered it to me that he's not a
subtle guy and i went oh i'm going to go
[ __ ] shave this off right i got to do
it oh wow that's some [ __ ] yeah you
know in dune oh man
it's like that dude he said he used the
voice and you went in and you shaved it
you blacked out and you shaved it whoa
who's the girl in dune she's great oh
the the
uh
zendaya zendaya
she was also in
little foot i know small foot and you
should know this because you have a kid
wasn't she also in the greatest showman
yeah that's hugh jackman whoever said
she was
whoever said she was hey dude there
isn't a movie that i would watch less
than the greatest showman i've never
seen it and i will never see that and
it's crazy to know that there is a piece
of cinema out there that i will never
watch and it will just
i will die okay and it will never be
seen by it it doesn't cross my mind to
watch it but it has its merits and isn't
wolverine in that singularity
got great music in it it was it was
probably not wasn't it nominated i think
it was it's got very good musical you
like musical theater i do you do a
little music i do theater i do you can
see does this answer your question
you
do i do musical theater you do the math
oh that's nice that's really the way you
wow you held that vibrato
yeah yeah i didn't know zac efron was in
showman too he's uh
no desire
zero desire do you see her in euphoria
though no oh i i feel like
drake produced it you never seen it he
did before you what is euphoria i don't
know that's about high school kids
basically doing drugs
oh yeah i heard it was my high school
experience was not like theirs they'll
tell you that much they're doing drugs
they're [ __ ] yeah i've never done
drugs
you haven't even drank never no i've
never done drugs and i uh but everyone
thinks you're on drugs right yeah oh
yeah yeah everyone thinks about drugs
you've not done any uh you never you
don't even drink wine no have you had a
glass of wine no never no how have you
not had a glass of wine
it's a beautiful thing did you think i
was giving you a tall boy when i gave
you this
no i know it like it's a waffle i know i
know it's water dude dude i i'm telling
you i know what it is okay okay don't
please don't please don't come at me
aggressively like i don't know what
it's liquid you're nervous i know what
liquid death is all right don't be so
[ __ ] why are you shaking dude
oh no it's not a tall boy right you're
getting them teased you drink secretly
at night
ah no wonder you look so drawn do you
still drink beer be i never drink i do
drink beer never well i never use drink
beer now i drink beer because if i drink
red wine i'm old i i don't sleep well so
now i drink [ __ ] sapporo dude i had
two sapporos
how about how about when i'm going tough
mudder some guy goes dick boy
it's 9 a.m yeah i'm there my son was
running before me because 9 00 am too
early here's a course i'm like dude i
get a running [ __ ] point i'm not that
guy
i don't drink a [ __ ] 12 pounds maybe
he wanted you to open it for him
no he said here's a cold one here like
made it clear like here's a cold one
they said there's amino acids in this oh
god and i went okay i'll drink it and i
felt pressured
oh i drank it wow
nine in the pool probably if you're
riding my kid goes what's that daddy
don't worry about it it's the carbs
yeah i i now i drink yeah it looks weird
on the right what'd you say yeah that's
a weird camera angle or that's just i
think it might be the giant tv
chris
don't you've heard of
what nbc
like tnt and stuff yeah i i've heard of
tnt bravo
honestly bravo is the worst [ __ ]
channel in the world okay i used to work
for them i don't okay well i liked your
stuff thank you
thank you that guy is on it where they
have all those fake shows where it's
like hey let's film every i know you can
you mean like the kardashians but
they're like hey let's film them do
stuff and then it's not that oh like
real housewives or something yeah and
then and but that show fine but then the
show
that they have where they're like let's
catch up with them
a year later and that guy with the gray
hair is like so
oh andy cohen yeah so tell me
when you did this and then oh you
recapping
nothing
it is true dude it's true you know it's
weird i did his show that remember you
were out there filming the joker being i
met you and the your
small friend you didn't tell me about
was going to be there at the bar which
really threw me for a doozy and remember
i had to go to the bathroom because i
was laughing anyways um
i did this show
well i didn't you didn't
why was this not weird
i i was filming uh what was that show
called chin with well my buddy does not
give a [ __ ] and he's also hates when
people treat him differently okay no
hold on i filmed this show with andy
cohen big show brian goes i'm right up
the street dude i go i'm getting done
here i'll meet you for a drink it was
cool i go just you goes yep
watch walk into the bar
watch what i was gonna watch what
happens live big show anyways are you
done with it no big deal yeah i [ __ ]
walk in not a big deal huge joke so i
watched
anyways so i go to me brian big deal so
i go to meet brian there ryan doesn't
tell me if they went through somebody
for luke his friend's there the the the
small guy from the joker and i told lee
and i got deadly i said lee i go i'm not
telling you you're here because lee
hates this this we're walking on the
street and he's like watch this car it's
going to stop for me they're going to
stop everybody then somebody gets up
there like hold the door everybody
everybody treats you like you're but
he's a great guy and he's not a great
guy great actor but he also dates the
[ __ ] really hot girls he's just a
[ __ ] brit who doesn't give a [ __ ] and
he's like watch this it's so annoying
that everybody stops and kind of treats
him differently instead of treating him
like a [ __ ] man which is what he is
and i said i said to lee i go now
brendan doesn't know
that you're a small person and i'm just
gonna have him come in and just let's
not have been fine i have no issues what
people are walking around guys how are
you doing
and he knows what he's doing and lee
gets up and goes hey how you doing and
brendan goes
you know what you said what you went oh
wow
[Laughter]
and he was a great guy he's a great
great guy he's a fun night in new york
wow that was great a fun night that was
a good night i love we haven't done a
new york night man [ __ ] new york's
been in a [ __ ] show you know i'm trying
i'm lining up now no it's back now oh
people are doing shows there like
christy d did but i'm doing uh i'm
trying to line up rhode island i've
never been to rhode island i've always
wanted to go yeah chrissy d did some
club out there he's like you got to do
it so i hit up justin so i think i might
go to rhode island in february that's
great i've never been there i've always
wanted to go like i want to explore like
the east coast rhode island might be the
last vestige of the old school italians
that's what i was in australia that's
what i wanted the old school italian
mafia like that might be the last that's
rhode island yeah
hey
that's not really what they say hey
we're in the rhode island have you
performed there
i never have really even back in the day
because i guess you fly into boston it's
a 40-minute drive yep that's all it is
which is great 100
this fight i'm really excited about this
fight do people tune in are they going
to be like oh you don't [ __ ] talk
about the fights should we or no no we
can talk about you talk about cabbage
hours this fight
so so just so you know this guy dan
hooker's a killer right yeah but he's
fighting
he's a fighter fighter i took this on
short notice yeah he's fighting he's
fighting the guy who's supposed to be
like the next the next khabib yeah short
notice that's that's tough right now
chris that guy fights at 155 pounds oh
wow now here's what else is interesting
is because uh when he lives in australia
and new zealand i always get those two
confusions because this is the main
fight i think it's new zealand right now
you're two away isn't he out of izzy's
camp he's out of izzy's camp so because
covert so strict there like one person
got coveted they lock everything down
they go around and his his training camp
whoever opened that should be fired but
uh in his training camp the cops will
come and shut down your training camp so
he had to basically do an underground
training camp because
new zealand jesus and then it was a
nightmare he couldn't get a visa to fly
out so he tweeted out hey let the
whatever whoever the government know i'm
trying to get a visa to get out to fight
they bombarded the
the
new zealand government so much they had
to address it and gave him a visa and
time to fight this fight
who was his last fight it was a [ __ ]
barn burner and he was all bunched up at
the end of the fight oh who was his last
flight jim
that was a tough fight man was it calvin
that's my son's name
uh he lost to chandler and that was like
chandler's debut he lost a point knocked
him out yeah he's had some good wins
though man well i think it was pourier
and he lost to pouring right was it he
lost to pouring in chandler oh this
guy's a nightmare oh my god
oh my god
yeah yeah
yeah did he win
yes
this dude is a and then then
i i think this is gonna i think that's
cool when you do that yeah when you say
and so we're gonna do that i do that so
what i do it's like very like actually
yeah because i'm i'm i'm i'm maybe right
hey remember early in the broadcast you
called me a wigger
we got it yeah
i still have a i feel no i didn't say
that i said you're uh you i did not call
you that i did no
chris you were here no yeah i mean say
no with the a and then
this guy's a nightmare
whoa that's actually cool yeah
um so that's what i'll do sometimes too
as i said
okay so sometimes you go yeah
this guy's a nightmare can you ever sing
it with the nintendo is that too much
what's that
man
i want to ride i do that sometimes too
i'm going to rock
yeah that's good it's nice when i get
off stage and [ __ ] the crowds going
[ __ ] nuts which they always do
thank you very much i did it all tonight
you know i did that and i got more so
and what about backpacking
so wait so and that that's a lot to say
at the end like in that rock style voice
and and and then what do they do when
you do that they go i've i haven't been
to a [ __ ] rock and roll maybe do they
ever go oh
and then well you do more and then i
come back out and i go you think i was
done [ __ ] the whole time in the
singing voice yeah well wow yeah yeah
that's really
impressive and then you go on and do
more comedy or what what's that so so
then after that you do more comedy i do
this at naples like that smaller room
you do this that's off the hook i'll
probably do it where i'll go you guys
ready for improv now and they go and i
go guess what and they go what they're
still saying i go this last hour you
decide they're like that was [ __ ]
improv they're like what the [ __ ] really
and then i launched into my [ __ ] it's
not your stuff
really yeah and then how long do you do
a material as long as i [ __ ] want
what because i got that much two hours
really it's about two hours sure carlos
so it's a three-hour show ain't nobody
getting up to go to the bathroom really
so what if they really have to go
you don't want to miss okay i understand
what if they really need to go bring one
of those long tennis ball cans and fill
it up with [ __ ] oh no wow no people
don't have to say [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] i got a [ __ ] in a tennis
ball no i mean i guess you could i mean
some people have to [ __ ]
in your show you're going for three
hours right yeah you might have to [ __ ]
yeah i don't know i eat a big bowl of
[ __ ] sketti before i go see comedy i
do teddy and [ __ ] daddy two of these
i drink two of these i drink a big bowl
of [ __ ] spaghetti and i sprained my
usually [ __ ] like 30 minutes in but
you're gonna do three hours three hours
so i got a [ __ ] in one of those pen no
tennis balls a salinger tennis ball a
[ __ ]
poo poo puma do they do it yeah tennis
balls
what the [ __ ] dude corks i'm gonna spray
and i'm sitting know what you should do
what is just [ __ ] get the tennis ball
can you insert it in your anus yeah and
this way your [ __ ] it's still inside you
but you already went
right and then when you're done and when
you're like you know got that what do
you do i go that's it for me
and i'm a guy and i'm like wow that was
amazing and i [ __ ] waddle out to my
car and grab the top yep
and then put the top on it toss it i go
home [ __ ] none the wiser that's right
you got to sell those tennis ball cans
as merch oh
that's a good idea yep bring cans all
right here we go here we go i got money
on coms out brandon has money on on dan
hooker well i'm sorry i mean
i'm sorry
racist it's not my yeah there's a tad
racist racist all good he has called me
but you know brendan said
brandon said dan hooker's it's a better
fight than i think people get hookers oh
half guard
yeah
i mean don't get me wrong it's a tall
task for hooker also shorter camp
it's a [ __ ] nightmare man it's also
this guy's
supposed to fight uh dos anjos
yeah what does he do here please oh i
mean you got a dagger standing blanket
on you that's that's a problem
and he's comfortable just kind of
hanging you're wearing that blanket and
it's not warm and it's not the problem
is if you just stay here and you don't
finish like khabib did you're not gonna
win a lot of fans and you're not gonna
get the title shot you're going to just
so you got to go for you have to do some
work daddy yeah hmm
that's interesting i never thought of
that yeah no i really mean it no yeah
yeah you got to be kind of a little
flashy entertaining you can't be uh just
a grinder
no like a john fitch type of vibe where
you're just taking guys down let's ask a
question if this guy just this guy on
the top here yeah if he just
leaned up and go and goes
and his splits yeah that you can do that
in the new year
no there's no spinning the street
me farted that's crazy you just winked
up are you gonna blame it on me oh he's
going for a camaro here
but you farted
he's cranking oh oh wow well this will
get you down shot a camaro no oh it's
bad oh god that's not
if he steps over the head we're getting
bad bad trouble here oh oh no he's over
if he steps over the head because you
see now there's no control now you got
to be captured
now that'll get your title shot [ __ ]
now here's the thing about hooker so he
went through all that trouble dude so
you know but through all the trouble in
new zealand not seeing his family all
that [ __ ] is that khabib hugging him
there yeah yep khabib's in this corner
this could be basically his brother i
know yeah and that was so impressive god
damn it dude it's just a matter of time
for that boy gets to the top i know
because that i mean the way he
dismantled hooker which isn't easy to do
[ __ ] no now you got to fight the lights
of chandler daichi you know poirier
yeah it's not a tell me charles oliveira
beats him maybe
i don't think so not a chance no i just
lost 14 million dollars
wow chris 14 what you put 14 mil on
hooker chris why didn't you talk to me
payout was going to be good i know dude
but you should 14 million oh no
i fell right i like the bed though
oh i'm gonna throw up i didn't know you
had that much money in the bed oh god
it's all of it
i
i'm gonna die someone's gonna kill me
for this oh there's the there's the
little dude
that's that's a bit disrespectful to do
that
oh that's cool he is just a rock he's
cute though yeah he's 18 or 19. it's
kind of weird
yeah you think he's in the chicks i hope
i thought he was five or six guys
no he's not five or six guys i don't i
honestly dude i don't give a [ __ ] about
that person at
know what he's talking all
he's not in my life it's not something i
think about i just don't give up chris
remember
farted in the leather chair dude that
was brian he keeps going like this he
would go i can't believe he did that and
he goes
no it wasn't me dude there's no way
anybody could tell that it was me and
i'm saying it was brian 18 dude
he's 18.
i was a genetic disorder called dwarfism
wow well i thought of something
different than that yeah i know it's
like gives them a childis appearance
with a small height and high pitch voice
all right well god bless them now
what's their average uh lifespan though
i don't know it can't be long they've
all got another week they've seen a tiny
bit live over 300 you've seen them
the longest lived people poor dan hooker
yeah what are you gonna do though what
the [ __ ] why poor dan hooker well he's a
little bit like cowboy right where he's
you you you call him up he's gonna take
the fight but it sometimes has to be a
business decision there where
he's doing that with bad matchups then
you get out of the race but here's the
thing also you realize in your heart
you're never going to be a champion as
long as that guy's there that's the
problem you always realize no matter
what you lost to pourier already you
lost your channel already so yeah
holy [ __ ] bro sorry that guy's 18 19.
imagine you're just somebody that
everybody picks up oh it's terrible i
would you know what i would do i would
[ __ ] i don't have words i'd wear
weights in your pocket
that says don't touch me nah bro you're
thinking inside the box both of yours
okay let's get outstanding this is what
you do okay
you never
use
bathrooms you don't go to public
restrooms you don't use the restrooms at
home
you just wait you wait until someone
does that [ __ ] thing where they pick
you up
and if it's forward you piss in their
face
and if it's out to the world but you can
piss you [ __ ] on their [ __ ] piss in
your pants bob no
no because you have a flap you train
[Music]
this is awesome i have a great idea you
tie it here and it's a flap and you
bring it under
over your shoulder like this so you have
a [ __ ] pulley a tassel right yeah and
somebody picks you up and you go
right in their [ __ ] face they'll
learn quickly
unless they're into that yeah because
the average lifestyle is 10 years he's
not that's what they're saying about no
we've seen dwarves out no no no have you
ever seen a tiny grandpa yeah dwarves
live longer longer no they don't dude i
hope they do the longest living was 94
years
that's forever
yeah well whoa
comes out and kyle just sent me this
what a nightmare
what oh that's chris
all right that's chris
i [ __ ] knew it thank you reuben
that's my
oh nice wow that's really awesome that's
really good yeah avoiding covet it's
actually kind of cool all you forgot was
a mcdonald's coffee in there yeah
i um oh it says life reps that's
hilarious
he's really good yeah that's good i can
uh you need to have that for merch i'll
do that and also the hair does look like
i cut my own hair so that's good hey did
you know chris cuts his own hair
uh i cut my own hair yeah yeah all right
yeah you're losing a little bit huh
you're getting uh you know not using
hymns or what uh
no i i don't know i need to
no look at those daggers and then
there's
just monsters wow
see they're picking them up again dude i
know
well i mean they kind of have to for the
photo it's gonna be so low you know no
you just zoom the camera out dude or you
just [ __ ] everyone else has got to
sit down it lies down on their stomach
yeah everybody gets the underneath
it's on their stomach
i mean i just feel bad for the guy i
didn't know he was i had no idea ooh our
five thousand dollar bets up next or two
thousand sorry five thousand dollars
peter young cory sane higgins you wanna
read you wanna you wanna you wanna pull
back pull out corey i'll give you a
chance to pull out nope
all right oh i'm nervous over here mr
[ __ ] nervous okay it's gonna let you
no no no no no no
if i go take a piss are you guys gonna
not gonna set tbn networks on fire can
you guys hold the four down hard we can
hold the fourth down you gotta go to the
bathroom yeah
bro i'm not joe rogan i can't hold it
right now i know he's amazing bro it's
ridiculous he pisses his pants he's a
camel i mean no he has a bag that's
attached to him yeah just don't spit
that rumor people like ah
i mean who would believe that he [ __ ]
well people believe anything
they believe he has a bag if you said
seriously you know he has a bag people
would buy it yeah
you know he has his bag he's back i know
he has a back i've seen it
yeah i've seen [ __ ] pissful yeah it's
got i think you should send it too yeah
all i've read it just was like that
i'm gonna pee before the co-main event
you guys okay bro are you kidding me
because i know you're not used to a lot
of this like now that guy's 170. that
guy fights at 170. how the [ __ ] does he
suck down the 170. that's crazy look at
him yeah now he's got his hands full now
he's got his hands full because he's not
going to wrestle comes out well we find
colby now i know that i'm saying
i know that you go he just beat a guy
not the time i understand but he's not
going to wrestle comes out he could yeah
i don't think so see you dude
see you later buddy
he never comes back he never comes he'll
sit in silence till he comes back all
right
dude honestly yeah
[ __ ] subscribe to my youtube channel
[ __ ] this what the [ __ ] hey does this
make you want to train harder now chris
train harder no dude subscribe to my
[ __ ] youtube channel dude don't use
this as a commercial it's just like for
you dude how many people are watching 17
18. yeah go over and [ __ ] subscribe
to my youtube channel and listen to my
podcast dude please man you're welcome
it's called congratulations i don't know
you know it's called congratulations
okay
i'm sorry i talk about all the
hard-hitting issues on my podcast you do
yeah like what i mean whatever's going
on in the world man yeah give me so what
is going on in the world give me here
come here give me the news
if somebody said chris tell us what's
going on in the world so it's crazy
first of all yeah right because covet is
just the way everything happened with
the lockdown and then yeah and then and
then uh people were just like okay well
let's see let's ride this out for a
little bit where they where where
there's masks and [ __ ] and then you're
being generally no no
new york had a big outbreak and then you
know and then they were saying la was
kind of leading the ring and it was like
ellie was like well there were the masks
and then it was man you're doing much
right what's going on now yes so i'm
getting to it you got to go backstory so
[ __ ] people are invested then when i
hit you with the now [ __ ] people are
like oh okay i get it but we all get
that so now what's going on now give us
an assessment of what you think
america's standing will give us some
insight in foreign policy and politics
so look it's diverse but what you're
going to say is you're going to say is
okay but why is it diverse and i'm i'm
going to be like okay what's different
people
no matter what issue you have in america
yeah
it is legitimate they split 50 50 down
the middle right so you have that so you
have you so you have trump you have
biden now trump isn't the president
anymore obviously
i know but this is the back story but
okay so trump isn't present anymore a
lot of people voted for him
and a lot of people so and abide as a
president a lot of people provide yeah
maybe more people some people think the
election was rigged yes we all know so
some people think the electorate right
but what where what so what is your
prediction for
the midterm elections okay so first the
republicans
yes first of all yes what so first of
all it's wild
what's what because everybody thinks no
matter what candidate you have yeah
there's gonna be 50 50.
yeah no not everybody thinks it's gonna
be 50 50. no no i'm saying no matter
what happens everyone's gonna go for the
fifteenth no that's not right boring hey
yeah thank you you guys talking about
the santa's 2020. no no no not the
sanchez 2024
you eating a donut are you eating cheese
whatever it is you sound exactly the
same as you do when you don't have that
in your mouth come on chris
chris sorry chris man don't he's
sensitive about him but no it's okay but
we got to rip each other but
when you don't have a doughnut no chris
don't you've been practicing no
no man listen i'm gonna ask you again
okay okay we're talking about desantis
[Laughter]
wow
uh yeah we were talking about the santa
switch before you might do it
florida has been crushing it
yeah and what crushing it how with the
lowest covered rates
didn't do it
they already they blew it out they got
it and they're like [ __ ] it and now
they're just like yeah dude i was down
there in the height of the pendant
nothing no mass nothing yeah nah they
don't give a [ __ ] it's crazy yeah that's
right
boy this battle you live in a bubble i
dude i don't i'm not
i'm not
a [ __ ] covid boy dude
no dude i don't wear masks in [ __ ]
situations where no one's wearing a mask
it's annoying as [ __ ] i don't like when
people are just like
when there's one person with a mask on
it's like
we're all not wearing it you're gonna
get it
you're gonna get it if you're the only
one here just go home
you know i do have a mask and i tell you
what dude there's people who talk closer
now because they want to prove to you
right yeah and it's just like dude get
out of my face anyway even pre-cove it i
don't want you that close yeah
i don't want you that close now you see
that guy right there yeah he's a [ __ ]
bitter yarn and he's got he's rushed 35
pounds
i've known him since he was 16.
so you're going to root for him very
good sure i root for him
unfortunately unfortunately
unfortunately
that was my first coach there christian
allen now is now he has a man bun is
this the main
fight his man does is this this is the
coming of that this is the main fight
this coming and that's the one before
the main one yes i don't like how many
there are yeah there's five that's too
many no no you'd like like two i want
one and i want the rounds to be 30
minutes each
five rounds oh that'd be fun a long time
chris
yeah why are you arbitrarily deciding
that like that's just kind of what i do
that's my brand but guy a human body
can't really take a decision
they pass the [ __ ] out and then someone
wins and then
they bring a pillow or something i don't
know they take breaks they [ __ ] eat
sandwiches in the middle oh man throw it
all up bro how much better would that be
no eating meals and fighting [ __ ] that
i'm starting that yeah
russia they're doing it meals and fights
uh
kristen allen is is a savant yeah yeah
yeah monster and a ninja yeah a ninja
yeah he's like i'm going to go get
whatever was in your mouth right now but
i'm going to talk so loud and still be
here that you guys are going to [ __ ]
you're going to get a doughnut you're
going to get cheese what oh cool
he [ __ ] up the whole backdrop
yeah way to go chris
uh-oh
oh we got their cheese daddy's plate
well there's some good cheese and some
batches on it right that's really good
is it nice man you're you're you're very
you look like a skater you're dressed
you're very dusty looking this is an
off-white
well it's not enough i'm an all black
i'm off black
oh you're saying oh is that all
expensive is that expensive gear
probably more than one
don't
be obnoxious that what do you mean you
don't know
the last thing i heard
before this was mine yeah was
will you wear this
please
oh so you didn't pay for it
don't stick yourself wow
[ __ ] your offensive listen mm-hmm just i
asked you the best piece of cheese on
there chris
can you wrap in the salami for me daddy
sure i will
so
the last thing i heard don't eat it in
an annoying no i won't
last thing you heard no i won't because
i'm a man of my word yeah
last thing i heard yeah
before i wore this yeah the first time
was yeah
will you wear this please
[Laughter]
so i don't know how much it is
shoot with your mouth closed you [ __ ]
it's
you're so obnoxious dude
so i guess somebody wanted you to wear
it because oh yeah then we get the brown
down
yeah here we go
and then
do you know what they said after i put
it on
what man the first thing i heard
yeah when this was
in my possession yeah
are you gonna rap one of those first
what dude
is hungry chris don't no i know but all
right don't eat that i'm saying the
first thing i heard when this was in
my possession what
thank you
he's so stupid
chris
so gross you know there are cameras on
you you can't
eat like that man why are you putting it
all the way in the back of your mouth
you're not a [ __ ] snake
you're not a snake you have teeth you
can you don't have to
put it all the way in the back it's
hitting the thing
or whatever the [ __ ] that thing's called
oh man i hate when people eat slow like
that
well they don't want me wrapping yours
now with all the [ __ ] saliva
oh look at this guy peter young what a
[ __ ]
i don't even need something he would be
in jail this guy would be this guy would
be in a maximum look at that
he'd be in a what
he'd be in a what he'd be in a maximum
security prison i think if he didn't
have a case
is it no i don't mean it that way he's
just violent maybe a nice guy
i'm sure he's a nice guy but he's
in
i don't mean that i don't mean he's a
criminal i just mean he's a badass
yeah that cheese is [ __ ] nice
i forgot i told my buddy i was gonna
[ __ ] have lunch with him and
he was like
when are we going look what he's that's
a real calendar look what he's doing
sterling look what he's doing
picking him up tripping him i mean jesus
christ oh man
now kyle have you had these uh nashville
chicken hot sandwiches
they're nice yeah where are are they
here they're coming here oh yeah got it
okay little and i thought that's all
right okay
this goes five rounds i don't like yeah
i just stuff it in the back there yeah i
know man
now
you've had the uh my my friends at al's
hot chicken how's it compared to that
[ __ ]
all these names the hot chicken names
the best chicken sandwich in l.a
yeah kevin said that all these names
with the chicken sandwiches it's always
like al's hot chicken or like [ __ ]
steve's hottest chicken yeah
what would you what would you call it
birds r us
you like that bird's arrest sounds tasty
i thought let's see spitballing ideas
here birds are uh you have just
different kinds of birds you know do you
have a vulture just a vulture all birds
you come to my pool vulture
sloppy i've got i've got birds that
don't even really i've got an extinct
[ __ ]
dodo bird sandwich ball wonderful you
want dodo bird stew bald eagle breasts
[ __ ] that's illegal yeah
you know they they shut down that
[ __ ] uh this this sushi place called
hump
and and um
they were selling whale meat and they
were selling a dolphin for real for [ __ ]
where uh
at the santa monica airport in
l.a who's eating dolphin meat at the
santa monica airport was it like the
secret menu like how in and out does it
they had some interesting sea turtles
sea turtle maybe
i swear to god you can eat sea turtles
santa monica airport [ __ ] off out of
santa monica airport ryan had a dream
and thought it was real dolphin there
many times brian had a dream and thought
it was real it was all great brian had a
dream and thought it was really humped
dude
singer ryan's big enough to be [ __ ]
don't even google it
we all know it's fake we don't even have
to google it put hump restaurants i love
when people say [ __ ] you know it's false
you don't even need to google it google
it right with your finger no don't don't
put sea turtle just do restaurant hump i
don't think there's a restaurant called
hump you know what dude i don't think
there's a restaurant that's what i'm
saying in santa monica that's how much
you're lying brian you made this up
look up i'm fine i just spit type in
hump restaurant i know shut down i
obviously mean
knows what to do
yeah but he's just like flying
you know yeah he's high no my computer
has viruses
on heroin see it's not working
chin's on methamphetamines
seal how about this literally sealed uh
whale do you keep gaming animals and i
don't believe you there it is
condors look at this look at this found
selling whale meat closes a sushi
restaurant called the hump that federal
prosecutors found was uh way too long
why would they be turning well
let's close its doors why were they
doing that though wow that's on new york
times that's been in japan hey you ever
had whale full of america so this is the
main mercury no co-main event god damn
it this is exciting this is me and
brennan have two thousand dollars on
this i got the russian guy bro this boy
corey yeah i'm biased i love this kid
see aurora that's my hometown i didn't
know if you knew that you had to go with
it you had to go with court you have to
you got it you got to go down with it
that's guy killing whales
but
why though is the demand that high but
also just serve tuna but that's what i'm
saying like what what the [ __ ] is the
demand there was a demand obviously oh
yeah really yeah have you ever eaten a
whale
no no don't get that humpback when i was
in the yakuza when i was in the store oh
god
it actually looks pretty nice though
i'll give you that yeah that's the way
yeah but it's full of mercury
oh shut up all right
mercury like out of tuna yeah give me a
[ __ ] break lead mercury you don't
want to eat hey brian that happened so
much
that happened 11 years ago dude i know
oh brian's bringing up [ __ ] like it's
news
you guys heard of napoleon
[ __ ] bring it up [ __ ] here that mafia
guy got shot at a restaurant in new york
all right you know what are we doing
dude guys i'm just saying
this is a big fight for corey
it's a title shot you know it's so weird
to me when somebody has no tattoos but a
huge backpack too
it's so weird what am i doing next where
are you getting your next tattoo on his
neck i bet not telling shh
only i know i can't stand when people
take something that's not mysterious and
make it a mystery like we're all waiting
with beta brothers
what you're gonna get on your [ __ ] since
you got the worst tattoos to begin with
a plane
a general plane dude and then a [ __ ]
eagle with a fire coming oh dude you
know what the weirdest [ __ ] thing is
what you made me think of this
you're a piece of [ __ ]
is that crazy no don't say that no i'm
not
you [ __ ] listen to me right now and
you're here in front of me and i'll come
at you but it's the other day we were
talking the other day we were talking
and in the middle of our conversation we
were facetiming and you stopped you
paused and you looked at me and you went
like this and if you'd been in front of
me i would have punched you in the face
you looked at me and you went like this
you go hey
you suck
out of nowhere
and i was like what the [ __ ]
and no i'm not i don't i don't wear that
tattoo or he did he did this one
remember the the guy he went to uh yeah
in prison yeah did he actually i know he
i think he got out
he was in jail
it was like involuntary i guess right he
drove drunk in a mclaren like crashing a
phone pole
the most talented guy i've ever
his [ __ ] was he still doing tattoos or i
don't know i don't know i should
probably text him that [ __ ] yeah
yeah he did this in like an hour
so oh wow yeah now he's setting you up
with him
yeah i've talked to him before yeah he's
just working great daniel daniel silva
yeah monster yeah he's great handsome
kid
um he's doing out of his house in the
hills and then killed that kid on
youtube [ __ ] awesome well the kid was
from youtube not on youtube they don't
don't drink and drive for god's sake
sorry everybody
don't drink don't drive hey take back
what you just said about me no no what i
was gonna say though is um
i [ __ ] you not no [ __ ] uh so i got
this because it's the tired eagle joke i
make on the [ __ ] man on fire on now
that's a peacock though yeah no this is
an eagle let me see dude this is
but but it's not a tired eagle that's
that eagle's on fire and let me see
because the special is a man on fire
no no my newest one is this one here the
uh
calvin i [ __ ] forget no it's uh
jesus i don't even know where it is
hold on i don't know where this guy's
hold on go to commercial ai
well he's over here carefully
what is it a paper plane a paper plane
yeah just a paper plane another plane
just one you're in the plane
yeah i didn't realize that i got so many
flight cameras i want to get a blues
angel
no so damn it
calvin looked at it and he says
i swear to god and he says not that and
every time he points he says that and i
don't [ __ ] know why i'm not even
joking because the joke
if you were a bird you would never be an
eagle it would be a stork [ __ ] it
sits on one leg like just hang out in
shallow water
eating with a sharp beak what would you
be b you think of pigeons
no you pigeon you dirty pigeon
dirty [ __ ] you know what you are you
know what you are dirty people one of
those birds that got caught in the
[ __ ] enron spill no yeah i'm covered
in oil
yeah no yeah
looking
[Music]
what happened it's going no i'd be a
[ __ ] nighthawk dude
yeah you're a dirty pigeon dude no
living in the nooks they're like just in
cities that was enron right enron no not
enough i was the exxon
they bought all those houses in florida
they have that rule where you can't take
their property oh they still have them
really they're in prison but nice houses
look at this this is a [ __ ] more you
know bp oil spill uh
why did i say enron
uh this is gonna be sound similar here
we go
this is an exciting fight chris you're
going to see a high level fighting here
you are good at one thing one thing is
for sure corey sandhagen you are going
to see an exciting fight now why would
corey uh sane hagan only get a huge back
tattoo and no other tattoos that's uh
honestly only something that corey
sanhagen knows but the way he trots
around he looks ready and boy i'm
excited callan what do you think i think
that his skin tone you know it's funny
because
you gotta you're not allowed to do that
to me what do you think i think that at
the end of the day corey sandhagen as
good as he is is going to lose to peter
yan and i'm gonna
peter yan is an absolute monster for his
statue five
seven point five weighed
135 pounds
he is not
looking like a monster but let me tell
you he is one now he's a minion he is
missing an e in his first name it's okay
basically it doesn't matter because it
still sounds pure now there he goes
there goes he's just shadow boxing now
if that were against someone that would
be devastating
right but he's not he's just kind of
punching the wind yeah here we go
look at how much taller
so you think you're going to go to the
atm
right after we yeah or what are you
going to do i'm going to i'm going to
unfortunately i'm i'm sorry that your
boy your boy bit off that's your boy
who's your boy that's that's right i'm
really close with him oh really
unfortunately and i think he's awesome
unfortunately peter young is a nightmare
no every time you say someone's a
nightmare they lose yeah they do thank
god i still want to of those guys in the
back market jeff won
you'll see
all right well i'm rooting for your dude
thank you sir yeah
and i also gave him the nickname the
sandman so be cool
and that's what they call them yep oh
really cool i give i want to give you
guys he walked in the gym at six he
walked into our gym at 16 just played
basketball had no experience now he's
fighting for a world title wow but you
bet against him brian you piece of [ __ ]
i had to better get something i'm gonna
come up with a nickname for somebody and
then it's going to go crazy nuts like
that one day peter john is a nightmare
right pewdiepie pewdiepie
peter
i feel like
i feel like mark norman gave me my the
he gave me the thick one because he
called me thick crust
oh he kind of start the nickname boy can
you call me thick crust i'll give him
that card you've had a lot of nicknames
i don't remember honestly
that was when i was fighting that's
different big brown's a good one i i
don't remember who gave me the nickname
of savior but there's
somebody
oh you know what's fun you know what you
want a funny origin story of brian's
nickname the kid what he made it up yeah
i know i know that i give it to you
because i know that you dude you've been
doing that forever uh hey hey you were
the kid your boy your boy's very busy
here your boy's very busy he's gonna
finish him dude he kind of you know he
dropped everything to fight though he's
not that busy
oh jesus he's just he's just more
dangerous dude
he's kicking his legs
wow interesting so you know why camaro
post that because they train together
and i watched them train together oh you
did yes wow it's always so [ __ ] i know
it's devastating but it's so [ __ ] when
guys do leg kicks it looks serious yeah
no no it is i see what you're saying
though yeah it always looks like they're
going huh i think the biggest [ __ ] move
is when they do the front knee kick well
that isn't that's really kind of like a
no-no right i mean i know they i know
they do it no i know but it's isn't it
like frowned upon not really oh really
the problem is you're close people's
[ __ ] christians
distance here and it's going to be okay
if i do this oh great body shot i poke
i'm respectful don't touch gloves
why not ah going for the kill you know
um
god one of these shots i would just
jesus
nine months
i'm surprised uh peter keeps on trying
to take him down
the reach of reach difference is a real
struggle for peter young right now he's
got to get close yeah ooh
daddy
that's we call that money in the bank
money in the bank what because that oh
oh damn
now he's catching us on his hands no
that's definitely hurting
oh oh [ __ ]
it's in tight
oh
now if he could just jump on there and
get his back that'd be fantastic god i
want to dress like those guys in the
back
where oh yeah yeah what do you call them
phobes
oh yeah but what's what's ooh good body
camera i'm just saying what ryan said
but what what what what's the actual
title that they have because you know
i'm a lord i've told you that chris you
are what's the deal with that what are
you talking about dude so my mom was
born and raised in england and somebody
bought me land and to be a lawyer why
did you think why did you take why why
do you say this is a bad fight for peter
you're interrupted because because he's
he's very stationary as far as pressure
straightforward boxing oh okay and corey
is a nightmare to deal with with that
he's kicking his feet and if he knows
what you bring to the table he's going
to be able to
he's just a lot to get through for 25
minutes congratulations podcast on
youtube
congratulations subscribe to my channel
congratulations smash that like button
kroy's fighting is very well smash that
like button do you want me to let you
out of the bet nope no i still got it i
got to stick to my bet bubba i bet you
knocked him out with a kicker and this
is him
out with a kicker this is where you know
more about fighting which makes me angry
but oh you thought you knew more no no
no but i just this is me with your money
are you going to do that with me
i guess that's cool i'll probably buy
you you're quietly coming i'm going to
do with it chris buy some new shoes nice
quietly confident what do you want the
mummies what are you thinking dude i'm
pissed at the mummies all right i'm so
annoyed still
this is hard for me to i can't talk
right now
it's just the first round but you know
peter young he starts slow a little bit
he does he does
but it's bad if you're a peter young fan
and he's on his heels yeah he doesn't i
agree and he's getting caught he's a
pressure fighter now cory's very white
like chris so when you land a jab it's
gonna show red stinky [ __ ] pinky some
guys get pink as [ __ ] we call pink
dolphins oh [ __ ] there's a kick for from
oh
wow this is a [ __ ] yes
man that takedown is not there but i
like that he's mixing it around he's got
dagustani hips peter young well he's
from russia yes he is yeah but he's
still getting started he's not no i say
he's got i call him there's no
hips there no i know
everybody wrestles different countries
look at that wow oh so baby see these
little babies come on now
that hurts too oh
did he get him jumping out landed oh
jesus that's what he's doing rory san
diego is a [ __ ] nightmare now you bet
against him oh it's all pinkish [ __ ]
look at his pick of [ __ ] yeah pink
dolphin there yeah
why are you saying dolphin it's a brand
pink dolphin oh so that's stuck in my
mind
but dolphins aren't pink are they now
who's this camera where's
where does jan fight out of you're hear
of russia okay
peter i'm sorry i'm saying his name
pewdiepie
guys guys
guys guys it's peter
yeah they should toss another e chris
now in a bit of a genius you wore the
halloween kicks on chris that's cool i
did i wore because it's halloween yeah
no dude that's chris that's christian
allen's protege creation correct since
day one molded him it's like you and
chris yeah like chris cory san hagen
you're a christian allen yeah dude
that's how it starts you know chris
allen gave me a little boxing lesson and
i took one thing he taught me and went
back to my gym and
i did real well
you know what it was it went like you
know what happened hey hey
hey hey don't care yeah but i'll go back
because that never happened
i swear to god that never happened he
gave me two lessons
oh what's this it's called
fob
it says thob or thobe
i thought i thought i had a cooler name
but what's their titles like if i want
to be one of them what's what's the
title
can i do it
i've seen people do it because you can
wear it you would wear it in the desert
you would that's how you conserve and
fighters would visit saudi arabia and
they would they would wear it and it's
like it's like a traditional thing like
it looks respectable this is a [ __ ]
you're taxing look at him look at the
way he's right
look at the way he's [ __ ] this is a
high level i know people are like oh my
god i can't believe you're on there on
tv i was texting about my son he's cute
oh what's going on with him he's just
being cute yeah he's watching
is he what yeah he's fighting
you you have marty he's like do you
think that jan or sandhya is going to
win
how old is he now
san hagen uh i'm sorry
oh
the peons get ooh
them boys are throwing
cory made some adjust adjustments since
the tj fight he's not going up his back
he's not doing those weird granby rolls
he actually got peter yon's back yep
he's young man
he's got tattoo at that box those pot
boxing yeah that bums me out i'm not
gonna lie he's my boy that boxing tattoo
buns me out yeah that's a football with
a crown on it so i don't have much to
say then oh damn that [ __ ] body shot
oh
you ever thought about getting your
tattoos removed chris no i honestly like
them still see you know why though
you know why though because you got it
when you were older yeah yeah yeah yeah
football with the crown i got one oh
[ __ ] right right right i didn't have
money yeah so like some guy named larry
did it you know
did it was his name his name was larry
wow they cost me 200 dollars i never
know a guy named larry period i've never
met a larry in my life except for that
guy 200.
that'd be my advice to myself if he
wants to get tattoos with your older and
yet money dude
ah or just because you're gonna regret
it yeah yeah yeah cause like what you're
into now yeah you're gonna do it yeah
yeah but you can be on your arm yeah
yeah true i'm so impressed with corey
right now i'm so impressed
it's just uh stylistically it's tough
man
what uh tattoos
those are tough too when you get them
while you're young but for so you have
ones that you you would maybe uh oh i
mean they just they just remind you of
that right
i don't regret it yeah yeah i just wish
it was like god there's such better
artists yeah like especially the space
it consumes oh my god he could do
something so much doper now
but that pace that space is taken
damn just have something like prime real
estate you know yeah go go have someone
go over it make it better
have a like call larry back up that
never maybe he's better now that never
works out though when you cover him i
don't know dude cory's saying hey
[ __ ] pete davidson's getting all his
tattoos removed i heard it's miserable
no yeah he's getting all over look at
how red of course san higgins bodies wow
i could help
i'd pepper you up just like that chris
you'd be so red you'd look like you had
a sunburn they'd be like you've been in
the sun you go no i'm running it's
actually a disadvantage when you're that
white and you should because the judges
see that yeah but you don't see like if
peter was that white you'd see his
entire body be like a lobster but look
at cory's look at cory's defense he's
got [ __ ] great
so it's a disadvantage you think because
of the oh yeah the judge you know judges
suck dude so they say that and they're
like oh he's
oh and cory's landing more but because
he's red or like some guys like older
fighters have scar tissue so they cut or
swell easier but it doesn't
mean dude don't blink chris don't blink
because you don't know okay
you know i see this spinning punch [ __ ]
a lot like the diaz bro this one's
spinning [ __ ] that [ __ ] really works huh
sometimes yeah
but i mean yeah like when it lands and
people get you know peter young trains
out of singapore actually he's muay thai
no no not at all no check that out brian
say more stuff that isn't true i think
it's true i do i think he's training
stuff about the whales before but his
camp's out of russia
and i don't like that i like that he's
switching oh [ __ ] uh oh no there's
nothing there okay i'm such a sucker for
ads in the ring oh crypto calm i should
get that oh sorry
[ __ ] [ __ ] i wanna watch the fight oh
brian oh brian pitch chris on your no
fun toast oh dude sorry hold on
chipping lines i gotta go to the [ __ ]
note there's some still some of the no
fun toes left nfc you waste your money
yeah no no listen we uh we're we sold a
lot of them no we didn't they're going
like hotcakes
what what are you talking about tesla
and no [ __ ] friends hustle them into
bikes
no they're actually hustled us but
they're actually selling well how much
your money make
well nothing yet yeah oh well that
sounds promising no but in like yeah
it's a slow burn you said yes so maybe
it'll happen nfts aren't though you know
they're quick i don't know i told you i
said i said we started laughing about
that's what that's what by the way our
portable proteins oh [ __ ] nah i got a p3
i gotta [ __ ] fight
god damn it i'm so such a sucker for the
monster underneath this thing oh i'm so
thirsty for monster energy distracting
boy he does come straight forward
doesn't he be
peter yeah these fighters came to play
one of them pinker than the other but
what's interesting is the body shots
[Music]
it's any man's game at this point
one-on-one
peter yan is somebody you don't mess
with and in the middle of the rounds
they're going to put refrigerator
magnets on his face
just to make sure he is not a
refrigerator no chris that's not so far
they haven't let go up it turns out he's
not okay so he's not magnetic he is not
a refrigerator
that keeps the other guy they're keeping
the swelling down corey
chris who do you have in this fight
it's one man i don't
know
and that's that
i would say i wasn't going chess brian
you were uh corey uh corey beats me by
just a couple inches
i will say though jan is so gifted when
it comes to making adjustments and i'll
also say what a great display of mma
striking by dude and san diego is
controlling the range and pace
beautifully dude there's not a better
cuck move to try and get on the ufc
broadcast by tweeting like man thank you
dana for this amazing fight card hashtag
ufc 267. oh oh caught him there
theo i do is a joke which is hilarious
and they always post it oh really always
what's he saying he'll be like man this
is about to be a barn burner ufc 267 he
always gets on there
that's my special [ __ ] spin kicks are my
specialty
he's getting caught man he's getting
[ __ ] caught who's getting caught
peter yeah yeah this is a good one
i knew you'd like this chris no this
one's a good one i knew you'd like this
wait till the next one too dude yeah the
next two are [ __ ] great fights
there's two more one more no no this one
oh god yeah
damn chin yelled at us
jesus chin there's one more
i told you he was on drugs are you doing
korean barbecue after this
chris nice watch
thanks man i made it i'm going to watch
it
i've made it myself you've had that you
collect watches no i just got this one
all right
i made it myself
you made it
i took it out hey the nike sign shoe
yellow huh yeah that's what happens with
these [ __ ] it's the sun i mean are
those the prestos yeah but i never bring
them out in the sun ever
i hunker down in my cave do you have a
window in your closet no
i don't
i don't get it damn peter yan is trying
to oh body shot oh up
these boys are scrapping scrap yeah
they're really [ __ ] scrappy both of
them i just want my boy cory to get that
bell bring it back to the rules distance
man
i just can't believe the stamina on
[ __ ] that do this dude i don't
do anything for this long 25 minutes of
fighting another grown man i don't think
you get better than these guys it's i
mean how much better can you typically
doug yeah
just unbelievable they do everything
good they do everything now remember the
only reason uh corey's entered because
tj was hurt yeah that's right so the
winner of this is going to fight tj
but t.j who does good channel tj versus
corey is a fantastic fight rematch yeah
after cory's made some uh
wow
corrections on his technique he's made
some corrections bubba he's made he's
not doing that [ __ ] granby roll
right
that's why he lost the tj grandpa roll
what'd you say granby room
what's that it's an old school up in the
kitchen dude you don't know the flavor
hmm
well oh boy
oh boy oh boy
all right
just standing just out of reach problem
is you got a reach situation here he's
got to get in there closer and it's hard
he's got to actually let him come in and
then fight him oh god then you get those
shots the problem is for every three of
corey's one of yawns does more damage
yeah he's up he's a power
puncher yeah
sits down those punches
small guy though huh yeah he's small
he's small tory's tall man yeah and
corey's not afraid
he's so confident
i was in aurora watching him smart
release right before his camp yeah he's
just getting he's just starting camp
he's doing 30 minutes of sparring and he
he was in camp doing 30 minutes
and letting the worst guy in the gym
beat him up because they want to go to
yeah he goes i want to go to the darkest
place
okay you psycho that's a psycho thing
yes like five years ago i was there and
christian just pointed to him said
that's that's the future
and you laugh like that i went
and then we then we rolled
i actually saw him
sparring a little bit and he threw a
body shot like that and i was like god
damn
dude i said to chris i go how do i do
that he goes it's complicated yeah not
for you though
wow look at this yeah
peter's gasps
ooh great body shot oh
oh [ __ ] oh my god sorry bubba sorry
about that that's what happens that was
a spinning one yeah that's what happens
the spinning one it was what's hurt him
yeah
but now here's the thing corey's no punk
down here he has leg blocks for days
now peter controlling that
now hold on now hold on hold on hold on
daddy oh
shove that oh oh that's tight oh that's
in tight yeah that's totally oh no
oh weird oh 40 seconds get to your feet
corey
shake him off daddy there you go shake
him off here we are okay at your back
oh he's fine he's gonna turn into him
and you're on bottom
this is how we do it this is how we do
it oh man it's actually the fighting so
much better when you're singing wasn't
that much good i don't know i got more
into it but it has to be the right you
know this is how we do it it's friday
it's going to be look at him
he's just both pretty tired now
now i think cory has better endurance
than he does
i don't know bubba we'll see yeah that
was a bad shot that's a tough one those
guys are still still not a 108 right
those guys on the top of the post with
the cameras no no that's not talking why
not i don't think so those guys on the
top of the post with the cameras are
they spy
russian spice they're russian spicer wow
that was [ __ ] very fun well they're
all wearing white dude 2-1 peter i think
peter peter this is how we do it
for the wedding
when you knock somebody down like that
you got to give it to him
well all the way up and then he knocks
him down so yeah right
i thought it was an automatic 108 round
oh no no no it's rare that you're about
10 8 these days i mean it's more
prevalent now because they're getting
more educated but it's you don't see a
ton of 108s in there
that was bad the spinning thing really
[ __ ] up right here
oh
that's what knocked out
he rang his back
i don't normally do duets but it's okay
[Music]
and if you're singing and i join in it's
all good you're welcome but like when
i'm doing it my [ __ ] is so i'm a solo
performer all right all right i know
it's hard right because when i do it you
feel like i wanted
i'm yeah so nervous right now because i
got i got my life savings on this oh
brian why are you betting your whole
life savings on this two thousand
dollars
oh wow we did a jump [ __ ] knee that's
that's uh that's frankie edgar out with
who that guy was feels there [ __ ] corey
sanhedrin is very much in this fight
for about
i will say for about five minutes i was
so tired and i stopped talking for five
minutes
[Music]
so now it's on oh oh oh [ __ ] jesus
[ __ ] busted a nut over here you [ __ ]
come on man oh god y'all giannis a
nightmare peterian is a nightmare dude
and every time you say someone's a
nightmare they [ __ ] lose he's a
nightmare speaking of nightmares i
watched [ __ ] uh
when i was a kid i was um
uh
definitely afraid of freddy krueger man
oh dude i had a poster in my room and my
mom i couldn't sleep with it my mom goes
good boys don't have those type posters
and we set it on fire oh wow she was
right
wow but she also bought me the poster so
i was very confused that's uh the most
confusing thing to do to a child but i
will say dude i was terrified of freddy
krueger oh me too well the wrong poster
i don't know oh wow my mom bought it my
friend cliff was really uh religious and
he said that halloween wasn't if you
have decorations you're inviting the
devil into your house well your friend's
[ __ ] he's stupid i believe it i
believe he's stupid
he had a haunting in my home and uh
and uh
i had to perform it i think even with
covert hell trick or treating's gonna be
popping right [ __ ] yeah right now yeah
this time yeah but i was so i was uh
so i i was terrified of freddy krueger
so i was like you know what i never
watched [ __ ] nightmare announcements
i watched nightmare on elm street for
the first time ever see
recently see brandon what he does it
doesn't really hold up
because when you fall asleep he's
curious every time freddy krueger no i
know but it's called he cuts the ring
because when he falls asleep oh i know
oh
oh play leg locks with corey
play leg locks with cory santa and see
what happens not a good idea that's all
he does daddy
so um and then i watch part two part two
that's the worst sequel i've ever seen
they don't hold up they don't hold up
now have you seen the freddy krueger
dunk nike dunks now they go for about
six grandkids yes they're i love them
buy them for me well you know it's
they're it's a lot of money to buy for
somebody just on a whim like no he's
tired bubba
peter young's tired right now both of
them are tired yeah i'll tell you what
i'm tired
he's coming forward though you woke up
early huh yeah i woke up way too early 9
15. oh jesus
that's a spin room move you don't
oh he's getting [ __ ] up peter young
got that championship good dude i know
god i told you
you can see though that that that guy
peter peter young is just like uh he's a
killer he just goes he doesn't stop he
goes goes marilyn bryant like that
[ __ ] guy ortega hey remember when
brian said if peter wasn't doing this
he'd be in prison yeah remember that
yeah and then he also called me a wigger
i mean yeah all right
you've had something weird
cory can take a shot by the way yes cory
san hagen has got a [ __ ] chin on him
he does now would you give corey the
round with the takedown uh no she's oh
take him down bob they want to do these
spinning kicks
i cannot give him a round he's getting
he's getting cracked and now he's going
for but he doesn't want to he doesn't
want to box with him so i don't like
that and now does this count as it take
that no that no there's no taking he's
taking this back no that's not takedown
he's defending the takedown but this is
control so it's not good but even
honestly even this much abuse for uh sen
uh sanhegan that that's not good for him
no do you get mad when michael phelps
gets wet swimming no no no no no oh no
but i'm saying do you get
do you get mad when tom brady slows up
football and gets tackled i actually do
get angry at that yeah look at this but
i will say um
though
peter you understand later on in life
takes it off his gloves and then he just
answers back
i was in the middle of saying something
right but um
sorry i get excited i'm not listening
it's not good for him like by the time
he turns [ __ ] 55 he's going to be
like bar no yeah but it's what you're
saying
chris yeah no i get that i get that
you can brian said he doesn't like
watching the punishments he's thinking
about not watching you anymore remember
that be i can't i love this i love the
fight
yeah because i live to fight fight to
live you know what i mean
is that right you're a comedian
yeah but i i i would say corey's down
3-1 yeah
damn
yeah
and now so he's got to win now then he
needs a knockout here this is the last
round yeah he's got something in his
nose yep yeah take that out before you
fight right oh all right chris you ever
had a bloody nose
yeah yeah
look at how calm he is it's not even
breathing look at how cory san hagen's
not even breathing heavy
well
not really yeah
it's rude what they're doing to his face
they should just let it be
yeah they're trying to fix the cuts and
stop them
get this oh look at him
oh wow what's going on here he said look
at me what oh look he's stuck oh [ __ ] oh
really
he's a savage dude yeah he's a savage
he's a young savage
uh now p peter john's the tannis russian
you've ever seen yeah is that fair to
say that's fair to say that's crazy did
he go to like the [ __ ] salon you'd
have to go to the tanning bed yeah he
runs with his shirt off he's not getting
russian son out there nah
i've never been there i have no idea
what it's like i think that looks like
you sing a [ __ ] king it's hot in
singapore bob
i think that's what's going on and i
think that you've got his style's not
very singaporish no he's either he's
obsessed with muay thai but remember he
was a professional boxer bowie yeah i
know he's very boxy savvy very boxy
savvy
i call that boxies god those guys are
lit in the back with those you with the
bubba [ __ ] and the b [ __ ] just just say
brian and i'm brendan thanks all right
man but i'm just saying yeah i'm just
gonna i'm just gonna like we've known
each other for a long time when did i
meet you
maybe 10 years ago 89 1989
when you were born 89 and i cut your
beautiful flowers
wow
trying to get into the club yep seems
like that
you might be not remembering that right
10 years 10 years oh jesus christ yeah
10 years sounds right 10 years how long
have you guys known each other 14
probably oh okay right better me
i don't but i think that we were both
under the brian's tutelage and we both
kind of
yeah he took my workshop
no where's your workshop i forgot baby
look at this me no oh yeah oh god yeah
they just kind of i'm too into this
fight i can't [ __ ] around right now wow
hey brandon you want to give me the two
grand now or what do you want to do you
want to back out i'll let you back out
if you want really yeah
yeah now you're like oh definitely
he needs a finish yeah
i think so
but we could just roll it into the next
fight companion too yeah
he fought a great fight though you think
colby cummington beats that no i think
okay i thought i was gonna get down
there what about rose and uh zang i go
with roses all day long all day long
roads all day long
all right and everybody
jesus christ i just sits down on those
punches and just throws everything like
robert roberts
yeah he does
and he just keeps shutting you down
it's what's the constant pressure
these guys are just going to wake up
aren't they going to catch 30 years old
they're just going to be like who's
cooking bacon and
nobody's cooking bacon and they just
smell bacon the rest of their [ __ ]
lives that's not bad it's not a bad
thing i know but it's just it's going to
turn into [ __ ] bleeding brains and
cancer and [ __ ]
that's fair well not cancer but yeah
yeah corey's trying to do whatever he
can
doing it's a good fight
yeah it's a great fight good input man
of course trying to do whatever he can i
don't like hey
don't be quietly condescending it makes
me mad i got one for you uh health now
think of a full-blown healthy
well-rested tj dillashaw versus peter
young it's gonna be sick it's gonna be
sick tj beats him yeah um i don't bet
against peter young bubba i just don't
i can't
i cannot hey chris stop [ __ ] running
commentary it's a country and i speak my
mind all right
i gotta get a good crypto comment
espn
it's weird advertising does anybody see
that in [ __ ] they do subconsciously
dude and then they [ __ ] get it by
mistake yeah like chris that's what
happens
every one of those apps what's that pink
logo
like you got to make sure it's clear
where oh yeah that's what is that oh
that's for aliens
yeah it looks very
good visit abu dhabi okay gotta go there
on vacation
it's supposed to be really nice
yeah i heard it it's like vegas on
steroids that's what dude i was just
gonna say that you heard that from hence
like vegas on steroids no i i just heard
that from hanzo no no tender's word i do
it's like vegas on steroids i heard that
from hansel
i don't like vegas though so you put on
steroids that definitely well maybe it's
[ __ ] god damn i just wanna i just
wanna you wanna get in there i just
wanna move out in to montana and just
you wanna go to montana i'll move to
montana with you oh yeah you love
montana love it
weren't you in arizona for a while with
the fan yeah
i like i like arizona i like there's a
weird uh fight would you move there
right now i mean i don't know man
i don't mind that i don't mind that i
don't mind either of those things but
you like the cactuses no now b i love
just like hugging characters
like piriana's putting pressure so he's
and i don't know yeah
no it's over bro unless he [ __ ] goes
nuts dude you'd have to knock him out
yeah yeah he's got to go crazy because
he's definitely down at least three
rounds you want to pay me in crypto
oh you know what i'll just give you my
uh cryptocurrency oh no you can have my
toads all right
jesus christ is so [ __ ] rough oh god
look at him oh god catching him in the
head like that i mean honestly the peter
young dude he doesn't even look
nope and he looks like he just went to
lunch yep yeah he don't yeah there's not
a mark on his [ __ ] face
and he's so tanned for russian
yeah
that is his hands up like that
oh [ __ ] he's kidding he's [ __ ]
dude
telling you
i'm telling you it's oh
i'm telling you it's bad for you
getting hit in the face it's bad for you
to get hit in the face
i like the way he dances around though
oh jesus christ that's it that was sick
how did he stand
how the [ __ ] did he stand corey lost
that fight yeah he did
now it's abu dhabi so you can get some
shenanigans maybe
with a wheelchair last last move was
just real good that was a great fight
that was a good fight did way better
than alex remains sterling oh yeah [ __ ]
man cory sanders then we're married
hold on i love this commercial
remember when i remember when we were at
uh the house with
and it was stallone and schwarzenegger
and all the [ __ ] dudes and uh the
sugar ray leonard and david blaine and
uh guy fieri guy fieri and then we were
watching the boxing and then it went to
commercial and i said oh an al pacino
and i said really oh hold on guys be
quiet i'm in this commercial
i'm in this commercial
did they laugh yeah oh yeah they didn't
even know they were there yeah
[Laughter]
yeah dude i mean yeah they're old i
don't even know if they heard but
brendan and frank heard oh that was he
got him with that [ __ ] knee
jesus
that's a good fight
peter's just a [ __ ] tough promise to
solve yes he's a problem he's that
champion just amazing
he just goes forward man yeah god that's
crazy that [ __ ] him up
got so many decisions tonight what about
let me ask you a question
what about uh what is it chris so
something that's really been pressing me
yeah no
i actually have wondered this before
like
these guys
that's got to do besides the fact that
it [ __ ] your brain up and like in like
you get knocked out
that's gotta [ __ ] your jaw up
no sometimes your jaw's all off but it
feels goes back right and i fight again
it
it feels like it's so like
sensitive like you [ __ ] your job
like nobody's the wife is a dime piece i
don't you're not a russian world
champion i haven't done correct correct
sir you are correct
do you think corey knows he lost this
yes
call him now ask him
quick quicker before they do it
look at the two there's there are
shenanigans hey there's so many bald
guys in the back you got dc you got dana
you had the the [ __ ] commentator
there really are a lot of bald guys out
of baldness you want huh
there it is yeah that has to be a tough
pill for courtesy
but there's no but you're losing to a
phenomenal fighter i mean he doesn't
care i know he's and he's great look at
his little son so cute
yeah
wow
what a stud
what a [ __ ]
stud the girl's distractingly hot am i
right about that
yes she is distractingly beautiful
and he is i heard russians have the most
beautiful well when you when vladimir
putin knows who you are and admires you
sat in russia yeah and he should be like
fedor is his right hand man but there
you go yeah
how do you not love this guy
he i don't know man
yeah i mean just a guy i don't know
he's not just a guy he's a different guy
all right that commentator's head's
weird huh the commentator looks like the
teacher from south park
okay
you want to talk about that right there
targeting friend yeah okay he's a
translator bring that
it looks guy up
teacher from south right that goes um
that wasn't instant classic that was
amazing what
oh
by the way and the push so disrespectful
there he is that's the commentator right
there that's funny oh spot-on
there you go that's the russian
that's a hell of a call that's funny i
could have came up with that if i wanted
to i just did oh jesus christ
his roundhouse is just catching
that's so that's so cute dude
look at that
this kid also doesn't give a [ __ ]
that's what he knows all he knows is dad
winning he's never seen his dad loose no
he's never saw his dad get
yeah that's it oh for what now alex
remains got a down opponent and that's
how he lost the belt sterling's got the
belt yeah yeah but he but he had to pull
out of this fight the south korea got
the short notice
he is back to being the champion so the
translators
let me ask you the
translator's
head his shape biggest brain how is that
happening
it's wild yeah well sometimes the way
you're born as you come out can shape
your head just thought i'd share that
with you the way they pull you out right
i know that well he might have a big
brain though
because he speaks so many languages what
do you think about did you hear did you
hear that shawn your head's perfectly
round huh yeah sean o'malley called
peter yana and peter young just tweeted
back smoking weed again
high high again shawn that's great your
head's perfectly round huh yeah look at
brian's head i don't know it's shaped
like an egg you know what's in there i'm
beautifully symmetrical no you know why
why because he came out of his mom's
[ __ ]
that's so she pooped out juvenile well
speaking of [ __ ] guys you what you
don't want is a hairy [ __ ] and that's
where my friends at manscape come into
play here the global leaders in below
the belt grooming the manscape
performance package 4.0 as i like to
call it the perfect package for your
package even your [ __ ] brian if you
have a hairy [ __ ] we can help you out
listen if you get this uh perfect
package inside
you will find their lawnmower 4.0
trimmer a weed whacker for your ears and
nose crop preserver ball deodorant for
your nuts chris
a crop reviver toner a performance boxer
briefs a travel bag to put it all in man
again it comes with a led spotlight so
you can do it in the dark in the water
do it underwater do whatever you want
shave your nuts on your time with
manscape the gift that keeps on giving
and if you go to manscape.com promo code
cfc you get 20 off in free shipping by
going to manscape.com cfc that's 20 off
and free shipping by going to
manscape.com cfc be thankful this
holiday season for the best gift don't
clear your throat in the middle of the
read for the best gift of all from
manscaped your balls will thank you
[Music]
for you
there's three too many you think i don't
know i mean it's kind of cool the way
you're doing it
to be brutally honest with you thanks
dude i want to hate but you're doing a
really good job when you go you
that's cool
come in
you like a lot of stuff like
advertisements you fall for a lot just
fall for it man
my heart
the thick boy heart thickness in the
heart
nah it's just like
you farted man
now you know earlier you farted oh
[ __ ] that was you no you know that
was him right yes
i find it disrespectful you farted on
the show there was a camera to catch you
winking at me man i swear there's no
back camera is there oh i didn't realize
i don't know
you're the one that farted
it's a slow wing too i'm not winking at
him yeah yeah dude who [ __ ] cares
about farts i used to be like yo don't
fart but who [ __ ] cares it's funny
when your kids fart
yeah even my son when he was one he
farts he laughs yeah what is that it's
just not he laughs
first time before he left and and i'll
tell you what and now we taught him to
say excuse me and now every time he
farts he goes he looks at me and goes
yeah
instead of excuse me it's so cute it's
poopy cute to see my son's doing when he
he watches his zombie movie with his
brother he calls them chambees
wow zombies
that's actually a racial slur for
zombies but
uh they don't appreciate it um
but it's cute
be more be more polish looking guys more
tough and and be tougher good work brian
just now how old does glover look he's
41. yeah
looks look how old are you chris he
looks way older than 41. i'm 41.
training dude that's a tough 41 daddy
guys he's been through the thick of it
but he's but that guy looks he's a
little tougher life buddy no he looks
50. yeah yeah well he's just punched in
the face for a living yeah and he trains
his ass but he but he looks healthy as
[ __ ] i mean no he's in shape
he's moving like he's 41 though
yeah but don't do this i love this
commercial uh sorry oh [ __ ] [ __ ] sorry i
get it don't don't buy it i fall for it
man dude you got it liberty mutual it
looks good
it's a bad commercial though look
appropriate how do you expect to sell
stuff like that bro let me tell you
something seriously zero good there are
zero good commercials
i haven't seen a good commercial in a
hot second dude i can make a [ __ ]
commercial and bang it out your sales
will go nuts so you know what i would do
for real i would hire comedians and
actors to get up and describe a
commercial they would describe the
commercial and that's what i would do
yeah yeah like what samuel jackson is
dumb [ __ ] yeah not this dumb [ __ ]
everyone's scared to [ __ ]
to do some real ad
man
you get me in there i'll sell your pants
they're gone all right sell pants
ah what are you doing what are you doing
listening what are you doing watching
all these commercials this is the one
these are the pants look at look at the
way they look and i don't even have a
shirt on look at the way these pants
look yeah you want these pants okay
that's it that's a commercial only in 30
seconds pants gone so you think i'm
joking
i'm not joking bud okay man
oh don't eat don't go double deep in
your mouth sticking your fingers all the
way in your mouth
now what
that's good cheese bro it is nice cheese
boy mike got us that cheese
oh you know what those that those
natural chicken hot sandwiches will be
just in time kyle yeah he said yeah he
said he's about 10 minutes out fantastic
what's the um
what dude i'm gonna i i'm gonna put the
link in my
box to this yeah
someone sent it to chris sorry worldwide
bro
but just dude i've called every fight
and we've taken all the favorites i know
it's not i mean i took all the daggers i
take all the calls the only underdog
you've taken is globally i don't know
yeah we're both taking globally yeah
yeah
but then everyone would have yeah
they'll fight for him tough fight tough
yeah tough fight for him glover you
can't count who is this is that glover
that's frank shamrock that's glover oh
that is jeff the [ __ ] out of here
look at him
wasn't he he couldn't get in the country
for a long time you were always talking
about him this guy yeah he couldn't work
here yeah like he was like he was
chuckled sparring partner for years and
then if like the hardcores you'd hear
all these rumors about this tough
brazilian you know him and chuck going
at it at the pit uh training center
thanks bud
world class jiu jitsu player that's his
background is jiu jitsu
oh nice
most submissions in light heavyweight
history is that true most finishes too i
think
wait are you sure this is the link it
didn't even pop up as a link
now if you remember jon jones dismantled
him pretty easy isn't that crazy yeah he
blew his [ __ ] arm okay weird didn't
come up to me like that but i'm sure it
works let me try to do it let me let me
hear about it
it's so weird it's stupid it's so weird
how good he is oh it worked
he dismantled everybody i mean john yeah
yes monster what is it what is it
like just history oh i look like a
vampire okay great great i look like a
vampire great
height mentality but it's it's a skill
set
i have to believe he works really hard
but people say he doesn't but i think
here we go
he works hard i don't know if he works
as hard like like cold hey guys fight
plum cam in fight completely
we're doing flight simulator right now
flight center flight flight competition
who's your favorite fighter chris uh uh
still style lender no um
uh zendaya john the zendaya guy yeah
peter tron sendai
[Music]
have you ever seen have you ever seen
our boy um is the dance oh yeah oh my
god he used to be a b-boy oh he was
that's why he did that walkout that was
with his old dancing crew he's such a
great dancer
i was like how the [ __ ] have you seen
that girl he walked out with no no
really don't even bring her up jen i
don't need that in my life no don't
bring it i got to see it i don't want to
it hurts it's painfully hot yeah
are you eating a boiled egg yeah
get out
you shouldn't get out leave no come on
dude i don't stand for dudes just eating
boiled eggs okay you can't do this like
this
look look
you were eating like this
dude that's
the [ __ ] no dude that that's the snacks
they gave people on uh uh [ __ ] squid
game chin i know they're good one boiled
egg and remember the gangsters took more
than their share
potato
hey brian
hey brian you know if they remake squid
games you're the old man yeah
hey you little man they better hurry up
they better hurry up and make it though
because soon you're too old to play that
part
it's okay but you pointed at me and you
said you didn't think you wanted me to
join that's why i jumped in too but
yeah so even if i'm like huh oh
there you are where you're the old guy
you pissed his pants that's cool dude
you're the old guy who pretended to play
marbles
yeah
[Music]
yep the marvel's one was intense right
the guy played with his wife yes that
made me sad you know if there's a real
games in this room
i win no what oh yeah you're out of your
mind you're out of your [ __ ] what
would you win i would beat you first of
all what would you win
the licking one hey here's the thing bro
i carefully hey he's got a big tongue no
no you guys you need a little thick tie
i get a chris christie yeah that's so
great yeah the marbles all that jumping
across the glass
and remember when they played him at the
end who's going to stop me there the
problem is you're not going to get there
no no no no
no there you go you're you're picking up
when we sleep at night in the bunk beds
[ __ ]
i killed both of you he kills us
hey with my hands you first [ __ ] face i
can uh figure out how to how what are
you gonna tell me you guys gonna team up
i know we have to i i learn how to scale
walls
and i and i'm up i'll be impressed
that'd be a problem yeah no dude that's
a big problem
you know the smart guy that just killed
everybody right that's me you would kill
everybody yep
and then if i didn't kill you and then
we we made it to the glass part where
you jump across i push you guys off the
side
damn it and then we get to that squid
game which is basically touch football
oh yeah who's going to stop me and you
got which one are you [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then we have to fight in the end the
very end you have to fight yeah we have
to fight with the good game thing you
[ __ ] idiot what a fight with a knife
you win dude
you could be the rich old gay guy who
like the vip guy yeah that'd be cool but
i'd unzip you remember when he was like
if you can get me off in five minutes
yeah i'll let you live but i would i
thought i was going to suck them off we
had to be honest but i would unzip
that's the reality i'd unzip you with a
little knife a little
you're not doing [ __ ]
no sir just want to make that very clear
if this squid games i'd
probably kill chin first damn you would
that might be a problem that'd be brutal
chin would put his name put everybody
against me it would never happen no it's
happening north korea right now yeah
that's real life you think that guy came
up with that idea nah that's it's
actually a documentary yep like you
serious why you say it like that brian
because my back what's wrong with your
back well these chairs are we need those
rogue and chairs maybe
i like these chairs but let's be honest
i think 2 000 chairman this is really is
that true yeah what's wrong with it is
it really 2 000. it's a very expensive
chair yeah it's not that expensive right
not yeah see
i know it's a nice chair though i know
but you said two thousand dollars and my
back's fine you want one of those weird
the wheelchairs roasting uses where
there's no back yeah it's better for
your back
i think it does because it keeps
welcome tbn listen
if you want to start your own
no i'm just saying i think we should get
the chairs that rogan has because he
keeps saying wait you keep saying this
is boring
oh sorry blacked out for a second
all right
well oh main events up here we go dude
and then we're getting our chicken
sandwiches yeah dude this is how we do
it this is how chris doesn't
tv show of the year best tv show of the
year the best movie of the year best tv
show your cops
okay
best movie the cops is cancelled dude uh
which you can watch on fox demand
exactly dude best tv show of the year uh
best movie of the year midnight mass
best tv series dude i want you to stop
talking about midnight mask how's that
dude
how's that
well what's better
oh squid dancer hold on i haven't seen
i don't know i don't even know if square
game is better do you watch yellowstone
no but i heard it's great get out it's
good right it's the best really i gotta
watch season sunday two hour special my
blood's in it and they're and they're uh
that's the dutton ranch they're an evil
family i mean they're i play red dead
redemption though huh i play red dead
redemption i play video games
no i'm not are you new to that or is
that yeah yeah i got back into it i mean
i played when i was a kid but dude i
started playing video games i do twitch
now they're on twitch flex avenue follow
me you've seen this player griffin on
twitch no but i'm not really i wanted to
yeah i know did you see the did you see
the mark zuckerberg presentation beta
you've seen that yeah no what do you
mean yes solid which part get off his
nuts no i'm just he's a villain
i know the matrix he's a bad guy the
matrix is here dude he's a bad guy well
why are you saying that though i know i
okay i get it
there you go it is really weird how much
of a
he really does look like a villain yeah
you know he talks on you too
it always like look just this matter
thing is every it's so funny ever since
elon musk came out all the guys want to
be elon musk they're like oh we need
personalities worth a trillion dollars
elon yeah but but but but him jeff bezos
like they were no they were not in front
of the camera until no they want to be
famous
right celebrity now right well because
elon musk is like the bruce wayne of
them and now there's these guys that and
and what's his name mark zuckerberg is
just like i i surf or whatever the [ __ ]
you know and you're just like okay okay
i i surf i serve that's it good that's
good yeah
i eat meats i eat i eat meats and i surf
i have a cooker i have a cooker
i eat meats and i surf hey i like how
you change yeah hologram i like how to
change the name to meta yeah
because they're getting all this
backlash so they think by changing the
name people just like okay well then
yeah the new technology they have is
very strange with vr and you know but
how about the fact that you can't be a
[ __ ]
you can't be a company that's like
taking over the world and it's still
being named facebook that's some
bitch-ass company name meta is at least
a it's a good name
do you know what matters
chris chris
no
i think meta is a good name
chris this is even chris
oh [ __ ] he's got a short
ox
meta
have you seen the
logo
[Music]
it's an infinity sign
meta facebook is
no more
what do you have to say about facebook
being uh bad for young people's mental
health
just makes me laugh
the
data
i know the
fake news
[Music]
auto adjust microphone
it's getting really great
learning
this is so dangerous
metachris where's chris the real chris
[Music]
in the metaverse well
what did you do to him is he no longer
y'all
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ]
yeah main event time chris do you know
what meta means
you keep rolling with your shots
do you know what meta means chris yeah
dude anybody 10 points for what meta
means oh 10 points oh [ __ ] wait no i
need the point
it's it's greek for universe no world i
know this hold on it's greek for so
metaphysics
meta metaphysical worldwide it doesn't
mean physical like meta meta peace means
i know it for [ __ ] sake meta
metaphysical what would be metaphysical
physical and then what is metaphysical
what all-encompassing no
it's not world
all-encompassing beyond all right beyond
yes [ __ ] beyond physical metaphor
yeah chris thank
education can't be that exhausting too
when i learn something i get exhausted
chris you got to read what what books
have you been reading lately i know you
devour books dune
but you saw the movie i know that's what
i do i watch the movie and then i
secretly i i read the book
i read them
kyle crawford bro
no real networks have guys crawling
yeah look at this here we go here we go
low kick from peter yan i mean from my
man look at these guys what's his name
this isn't the set of avatars you guys
walk across
dude these guys literally look like guys
you'd bring your car they are meaty guys
by the way they look like they can get
down there they do look like one's 42
the other is 39. these guys would fix
your car and
charge you so much dude you'd be like
it's really that much and he'd be like
it's everything is delayed because of
kovitz it's just a sport
now one thing you need to know chris
glover is a very good wrestler oh great
grandpa very very very very really good
grappler he got something oh [ __ ]
lover's the white white guy the white
guy
he's brazil he's a nightmare he's a
nightmare wrestler
don't be surprised if you see a
submission here
although even though he's in the guard
yeah uh no he's not going to submit him
from top guard oh yeah i know in my
lingo
no bryant said yeah so
did you train with clover yeah you did
yeah black house wrestled with him did
everything sparred wrestle nightmare
right wrestling yeah
super stud
now brennan chris what you don't know is
brendan's much bigger than these guys so
what happened tonight
not really though no no like he walked
around 230 i might have had eight pounds
stronger than he is
yeah yeah but like he's strong so i was
like maybe 235 238 so you know you
better have eight pounds on them now
you're bigger you bam bam you you were
250. you always saw that i've never seen
it it drives me crazy i was never too
fast the lightest you were when you was
when you didn't mention sir 236 yeah
when you i thought andre alaska at 236
really yeah it's very very true heaviest
i was ever waiting at the uc was 241
really yeah i was never heavy never 250.
what um
the dude that uh [ __ ] i forget his name
no the the guy who announces all of it
the world championships the world champ
no no that dude
sorry he's black he's got the bald z yes
he um
he what does he weigh
right now
yeah well now right yeah yeah okay no i
just want you heavyweight he's like 240
yeah 250. fought at 205 though for most
his career fought a heavyweight two
thousand
heavyweights
lost never lost to the heavyweight
he did he lost twice dude no i'm saying
when he
before that before we went to
heavyweight like in the beginning and
then he was like
john jones yes okay don't argue about a
heavy weight before i'm so nervous guys
i don't do well with confrontation guys
i don't do all the confrontation
well he's saying he never lost him don't
be so nice he
by the way
if glover wins this if he wins the title
it'll be such it'll be so [ __ ]
amazing for him great story great story
a great story
ridiculous
now yuri might have something to say now
let me ask you this when you win a
championship in brazil you held as a
hero the way you are in russia you don't
have the same perks
uh yeah that's i'm in russia or god
brazil though you know
all the people love you why do they
value it so much in russia because
they're that's what they do it's like
they're lebron you know i'm sorry it's
the main sport out there wow
wow it's in brazil too i mean soccer is
bigger but it's a pretty big deal wow
in america we really don't give a [ __ ]
mm-hmm
yeah yeah you're not lebron yeah yeah
yeah we got tom brady
okay i'm not arguing i
but although conor mcgregor is [ __ ]
he's huge yeah but
he's he's ireland right it's it's oh
right i got oh i see you're saying as
far as like our i got it i got it
because you were deante wilder was
heavyweight champ for a long time no one
really gave a [ __ ] boxing yeah but yeah
really good fun but then tyson fear in
england anthony joshua and england
[ __ ] gotcha yeah that's true but here
we just don't you know we got too many
heroes
that fight was crazy huh the the wilder
fury fight that was curious crazy you
know it's crazy if you knew it yeah yeah
that's how you know it went mainstream
yeah well i watched it oh really yeah
well
paid for it yeah wow
and i but i paid for the ortega one too
the
yeah i i don't know i've been watching
lately i really have yeah well once you
start watching them you get and you
start the super high level ones yeah
they're great okay i like that just that
fight you start with peter young and
corey santana is as good as it gets you
don't get better right now i mean jan is
losing every minute of this fight
yeah
yeah he's stealing we'll see if he can
get him down oh he's cranking his neck
that's called his neck crank but no
one's going to tap no one's going to tap
from that no no a polish guy's not going
to tap from a neck rank although that's
[ __ ] cranking that sucks dude that
really
wow there's nothing for me i don't think
i've seen a neck crank in a hot second
yeah i don't think i've ever seen one
look like regular people tap from that
all the time
that's a [ __ ] what do you do when
you're getting neck rank push this way i
[ __ ] all over my opponent
okay okay
and you're all covered in poopoo
yeah
i almost want yonder well he doesn't
need a translator i want that south park
translator jump back in there
yeah but that's polish
yeah by the way knows polish you're
right
daniel cormier cormier cormier
cormier
such a badass
he's 42. i mean even the fact that he's
42 is crazy to me crazy
i don't know though like sometimes i
think maybe just because i'm me like i'm
like maybe i look 41. you know you do
yeah i guess i look 41. i guess i do i
don't know like to me you know i don't
think of you as 41. yeah because you
dress you dress like you're in your
teens right dude don't you yeah i am
dressed like 18 i'm very
yeah wait how old are you 38
yeah
i don't i don't but i feel like it's
different now like 40s like the new 30.
yeah unless you're chris and you don't
do any exercise and you don't take i do
i don't know you don't get any you don't
get any minerals the only time i think
of ages and i'm not trying to be shitty
with brian yeah i look older but with
like
i can't tell you how theo is no clue
yeah
i know how it is because he's 27 or 52.
i don't know
by the way here we go with the strike
stevie
bobby lee i have no [ __ ] clue out
there well bobby's 50.
and that that is up wild
that is well yeah now because stevie's
like 48 but he
have no clue they look young as [ __ ]
dude that asian it's just crazy
yeah you don't wanna you don't wanna
yeah
a little bit better striker sorry yan is
uh that's got the russian yeah
there's no brazilian name yawn well yeah
i don't even know jesus listen man
this is actually exciting
hell yeah brian a couple of meaty guys
too just big meaty guys keep giving it
though yeah meat just a lot of meat keep
going chris yeah a lot of meat they sure
do have meat on them yeah i got a lot of
meat on them yeah dude you guys aren't
playing around
i'll tell you one thing about these guys
they're not playing around
that's a good analysis yep
and watch those knees you know what i
mean
is so weird it is i don't understand
it's another language yeah like what's
that bottom it's cha it's chinese yeah
it's
narnian it's out of squid games yeah
look at that beautiful [ __ ] he's good
he's that that uppercut that lead
uppercut
yeah oh he's he's like all right you
want the takedowns i can't believe
you've been [ __ ] hit by guys like
this dude
insane i mean do you feel bad for me
no but does it i mean does it
hurt yeah do you feel bad for me no i
know it yeah i do yeah does it i know it
hurts oh
oh my god
yeah oh
we can hit now clover gets power too
yeah don't get twisted he might not hit
as hard as young but he lands that's
trouble
guys coming back throwing these thangs
jesus oh god
that left hook
that left hook is there for glover i'll
tell you that right now yeah
dude
i'm uh uh oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah another round for glover
yeah i think clover is going to win this
guys it's glover not glover glover
clover huh dude um
danny glover all right here we go
she's related nice
god man
god it's crazy how much holy mount city
okay i bet john turns to his back he's
gonna choke him out your boy called it
why would he coming up hit me chris i
want the world
that was [ __ ] incredible phenomenal
dude that's such a journey
it's such a journey for him why why he's
40 he's 40 yeah he's like he's high
school dude he fought john for the title
and got annihilated and then he like had
a few losses now he's true he's knocked
out by uh he's the world champion
anthony he trains in connecticut you
[ __ ] guys could you bring connecticut
jesus nothing more well deserved than
that yes wow god [ __ ] wow chin's
fired up i'm so happy chin's about to
cry why are you laughing jim's gonna cry
because because he came back from like
everything he came back and then yeah
it's a true rock and destroyed
if rocky was an older brazilian this is
rockstar wow so brazilian's going nuts
right now of course yeah what are your
[ __ ] loss
they'd go more nuts if you lived in
brazil but he's been in america so long
you know dude he's a world champion of
connecticut oh my gosh
that's insane
look at that just took that he got his
take when i tell you about him going to
his back oh how'd you know though you
know i've been around the game
but but like you can't you don't know
how you knew or you do know how you knew
and you just felt it i kind of know dude
i i picked everybody to every winner i'm
so [ __ ] good this is the this is this
i called glover it was in my draft this
show belongs to me guys this show
belongs to me i'm i i kind of won this
show tap quick yeah yeah it's like ready
to go fight companions
that hurts what is the winner of it is
that a chin crank
that was on the neck was it a choker
that was choked
that's crazy he won wow paul felder's no
not a word does paul felder not look
like stephen king
the paul felder is so awesome
god damn it that guy looks like he's
stephen king he's a young better looking
son
two bald guys just chatting it up right
now look at that
he's just talking about who he's amazing
he's a champion
that's so cool god he did now look at
the ref bald what is going on
it must be hymns is all over this promo
code btb all right
on bald crimes two rich bald guys
talking about his mother look at his
wife is that his wife or his girlfriend
or whatever that's his wife in the black
and that might be his daughter with the
blonde dying piece or the or or his mom
and his girlfriend no that's his name
that's his wife i'm not gonna tell you
again and don't say it's his mom but
that's awesome that's his wife she's
been she's been by him forever yes you
have no idea you have no idea oh my god
that's amazing i'm so happy
look at him how great is that what a
great guy too he's a great [ __ ] guy
wow look at that ref that's made some
poor decisions yeah that's it whoa
that's a lot of tattoos what's going on
he has an ekg on the side of his head
that guy's probably been some dark
artists what does ekg
what do you think he said
you heard a key i don't know i thought i
could
you need to
you need to brush up dude okay man i
will i will i will don't bend
that's the game ah but they could
rematch although yeri is waiting and i
that's a tough matchup for glover
that dime piece yerry i would almost
retire now
like he did it no no no but here's where
it's crit now is where you get money
like you don't get money here you get
money once you get the bill so now you
want to keep that thing
just two solid guys how about the hair
on the his coach there
where i don't know it's just high
testosterone there's a lot of bad hair
anybody noticing this yeah it's not
really a thing though like brian has the
best hair in the octopus did they these
guys fought right didn't they i think no
never no i don't think so
okay
there's a translator
but not the one from south park that
guy's been the translator for the
brazilians forever
yeah
he's like this yeah
kyle you're into this huh she's falling
in love oh god that was great whoa it's
we've we've been here for a hot second
three hours
no this been three hours yeah three and
a half three and a half holy [ __ ]
it feels like we just got started oh
don't say things that people just say no
no i'm an orange county real estate
agent like you are speaking of orange
county i'll be at the bridge oh god i
remember fourth and fifth any chance you
give them chris november 11th to the
fourth the spot this thursday friday la
crosse come on guys
i'm only running 30. now he's gonna open
for me you wanna open them i'm not doing
i'm only running 30.
you want to do you want to just ten
minutes do you see how close that is for
you bro
so far
yeah but i'll try it out dude don't
you're not doing me a favor by doing it
i'll throw you up
dude
how long get up there and [ __ ] around
and then i'll come up and i'll
show you how it's done
dude
if i wasn't so hungry i'd laugh at that
we got nashville chicken hot sandwiches
for you dude i'm excited where they're
not here though are they i bet they're
here they're here they want to have
they're ready they're hot let's go hey
you like hot food right let's go eat
dude you're not selling me on hot food
of course i like [ __ ] hot food hey
it's not your idea hot food hey you've
heard of
cnbc right oh [ __ ] dude this is yes this
is tbn welcome tbn
it's over don't welcome me now
congratulations podcast fans i want to
thank you guys for asking about chris
don't really confine you if they don't
know who the [ __ ] congratulations
podcast on youtube i do it every week
and i [ __ ] you're also on patreon too
yeah yeah patreon and you got merch
chris yeah it's all good it's gonna be
the opening for me no i will he'll be at
the hall this thursday friday
and then dallas that's an improv we're
gonna add shows those [ __ ] are almost
sold out get tickets at f a t k z dot
com that is no
what are we in [ __ ] november 11th
through the 13th i will shoot my
30-minute special
dallas texas addison improv 11th through
the 13th and just announced everett
washington one night at a theater and
everett washington i think it's like 30
minutes that guy's your next light
heavyweight champ he's a dime piece way
better look at anybody here either way
everett washington everett theater
whatever the theater it's haunted
whatever november 27th one night only
november 27th everett washington but
dallas you're up november 11th through
the 13th ha this thursday friday guys
love you love you too so glad we did
this this is the fight campaign so the
boys can get back together chris i
[ __ ] love you you're the finest man
in the world love you guys thank you
thank you for doing this we're out
you